Ja.
Ich habe mir jetzt von zu Hause diesen Wecker mitgenommen,
der jetzt bei mir
in der Küche steht, hast du vorhin schon gesehen.
Wunderschöne, rote Retro-Mutin.
Das sieht so richtig kacke aus.
Nicht kacke, das Retro.
Vielleicht stelle ich mir mal wieder einen mechanischen Wecker
auf den Nachttisch, habe ich mir gedacht.
Dann habe ich den nach 10, 15 Jahren
zum ersten Mal wieder aufgezogen.
Der geht direkt.
Weiß ja auch Qualitätsware von damals.
Pass mal auf.
Den hört man durch die Tür durch.
Das ist total krass.
und deswegen habe ich ihn in die Küche gestellt
und dachte mir,
du darfst jetzt hier austicken,
wo du mich nicht störst,
bis die Feder wieder entspannt ist
und dann ist mir allerdings
nicht aufgefallen, dass da
Folgendes passierte, wenn ich den zu doll auf den Tisch stelle.
Achte mal genau drauf, was jetzt hier passiert
und beschreib mal bitte, was passiert.
Na gut.
Das war jetzt sogar Zufall,
dass der angefangen hat zu klingeln,
aber das ist überhaupt nicht die Zeit, die eingestellt ist.
Aber er klingelt trotzdem.
Was zumindest passiert ist, dass wenn ich den hinstelle, jetzt geht auch nicht wieder runter, dann geht dieser Nupsi, der Nupsi, mit dem du den Wecker anmachst, geht dann einfach hoch.
Also der Snooze-Button entsnoozt sich und somit ist der Wecker scharf gestellt.
Der Wecker war scharf gestellt und das wusste ich gar nicht.
Und ich hatte da die Zeit aber nicht eingestellt, das heißt,
der stand auf 6.30 Uhr
und heute ist, ich muss dazu sagen,
heute ist der, was ist er eigentlich
für ein Feiertag?
Heute ist amtlicher Feiertag in Sachsen
und ich wollte halt eigentlich ausschlafen.
Dann klingelt plötzlich 6.30 Uhr
aus meiner Küche, dass ich es durch die gesamte
Wohnung höre,
dieser scheiß Wecker.
Das ist voll das Feature, dass durch das Aufstellen,
der sich scharf schaltet, da kann man es nicht vergessen.
Ja.
voll das Feature.
Hi Kilian! Hey Hendrik!
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge
35, liebe Zuhörer.
Und
ja, heute ist
ein besonderer Tag, denn
wir machen eine Folge mitten in der Woche,
mitten an einem Nachmittag und das ist ein,
wir haben frei, das ist cool.
vermutlich daran, dass du gerade eben erwähnt hast,
dass es Buß- und Betag ist.
Ich habe auch vergessen, was es für ein Feiertag ist.
Das ist ja auch nur so christlicher Bullshit. Aber an Feiertagen
finde ich Religion wieder toll.
Ich meine, man muss keine Religion haben, aber
Feiertage könnte man mehr haben. Also Feiertage ist gut.
Und ein Buß- und Betag beibehalten.
Man kann auch gerne säkulare Feiertage haben, muss ich sagen.
Sowas wie Tag der Deutschen Einheit
oder sowas, wo was gefeiert wird,
womit man tatsächlich was anfangen kann.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was hier an einem Buß- und Betag
Das ist dann eher ein katholisches Konzept, oder?
Busen und Beten.
Buße tun ist ja, glaube ich, wirklich so ein katholisches Ding.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe null Ahnung.
Anyway, heute ist frei.
Ist immer sehr witzig, wenn du Leuten erklären musst.
Übrigens, also meine amerikanischen Kollegen,
mit denen ich täglich kommuniziere,
denen ist wahrscheinlich nicht mal unbedingt bewusst,
dass unser Team und das andere Team aus Deutschland,
was in Karlsruhe sitzt, nicht im gleichen Bundesland sind.
Deutschland ist ja quasi ein Staat von der Größe her.
Und deswegen haben wir dann witzigerweise
immer so Situationen, ja, an dem Tag
ist Deutschland Feiertag, sagt der eine.
Und dann so, nee, bei uns nicht,
sagt der andere. Traurig. Neulich war irgendwas
in Karlsruhe und dieses Mal ist es bei uns.
Und dann
fallen so Meetings aus und die Leute kommen nicht.
Und dann denkst du so, hä, warum? Na ja, die haben gesagt,
bei euch ist Feiertag. Nee, ist nicht.
Und jetzt ist es so.
Meine Kollegen sind ja auch fast alle in Hamburg.
Die dürfen heute arbeiten.
Die machen gerade ihr Schönes,
sogar wirklich gerade jetzt,
das Sprint Planning. Können die auch schön mal machen
an einem Tag, wo ich nicht darf.
Eines der langwierigen,
super spannenden
in Anführungsstrichen Meetings.
Ja, wie lange dauert so ein Sprint Planning bei euch?
Unterschiedlich, aber ich glaube
unter zwei Stunden war es noch nicht.
Eieiei.
Naja, das kann sich immer hinziehen, je nachdem
mit wie vielen Leuten du das machst. Wir haben das bis vor kurzem
mit allen Leuten auf der Etage
gemacht, so mit 20 Menschen.
Boah.
Das zog sich dann hin und dann haben wir auch festgestellt,
es gibt irgendwie, wenn ich eine Linie durchziehe,
die Leute machen was und die Leute machen was
und es überschneidet sich nie.
Lass uns das mal wieder aufspalten
und jetzt sind unsere ganzen
zwei wöchentlichen Events wesentlich
kürzer und effizienter geworden.
Jetzt kommt zwar manchmal so ein
Manager bei uns rein und sagt,
wie ist denn das und das?
Das haben wir doch heute vorher erzählt. Ja, da waren wir aber nicht mit dabei.
Ach stimmt.
Aber alles in allem hat es sich gelohnt,
das zu machen, muss ich sagen.
Wir haben noch
Follow-up und zwar ist nicht nur
Go scheiße, sondern auch Rust
und jede andere Sprache
Es gibt jetzt für jede Sprache eine.sucks-Seite?
Nee, ich habe eine schöne Seite entdeckt
wiki.theory.org
Rust.sucks ist noch frei
Die haben die Seite
Your Language Sucks
und da sind Einträge für
viele Sprachen, leider Swift nicht
weil Swift sagt ja auch nicht
aber Objective-C ist mit gelistet und
Swift auch mit angesprochen
aber Rust hat tatsächlich recht viele Punkte
die, warum Rust stinkt
wir können da jetzt
drauf eingehen oder es einfach sein lassen
bevor Hendrix sich hier persönlich
gekränkt fühlt. Ich nehme das nicht persönlich
wenn
wenn es alles berechtigt ist. Rust-C
ist slow. Aber man kann da generell
erstmal mal durchhören, das sind echt viele valide Punkte
gerade so auch bei Ruby, so eine Sache, die mich immer gestört
habe, so dass es diverse Aliase für Funktionen
gibt und
da hat auch das Ding von, da habe ich noch nie was gehört, was
Backbase
Wo guckst du gerade hin?
In der Contents ganz oben.
Das ist ja ein Media-Wiki.
Ach, das ist eine Sprache, meinst du?
B-A-G
oder was?
Nee, B-A-C-K-B-A-S-E.
Und da steht einfach nur, oh really, this subject could take
a whole new Wiki by itself.
Wie lange ist denn die Liste für PIP?
Sucks because.
Oh ja, da muss ich ein paar Mal scrollen.
Oh, ich scroll immer noch.
Okay, jetzt kommt Pearl.
Pearl sucks because.
Wollen wir da jetzt in jeder Folge
eine Sprache rauspicken?
Wir können ja wirklich mal so ein recurring
Thema machen hier von wegen, heute bashen
wir diese Sprache oder
diesen Messenger. Allein, dass das Wort bashen
heißt.
Das ist mir gar nicht mal aufgewollt.
Dann fangen wir direkt mit Bash-Bashen an nächste Woche.
Bash-Bashing.
Titelvorschläge.
Ah, meine Tasse tut es nicht mehr.
Was ist los?
Ich mache das an dem Pad.
Ich verfolge das Ding für dich.
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade erzählen, dass ich
unser letztes Sprintplanning auch verpasst habe.
Weil ich jetzt nämlich eine Woche nicht da war.
Und dann bist du perfekt
übergeleitet zu Rust gegangen. Ich war nämlich auf dem
Rustfest.
Das war ja jetzt, stimmt.
Das war jetzt. Das war in Barcelona.
Dieses Jahr gab es nur eins.
Normalerweise ist es,
bislang war es
Binanual?
Ne, wie heißt das? Zweimal im Jahr?
Biannual.
Immer eins im Frühling und immer eins
dann im Herbst und dieses Jahr
ist das im Frühling aus organisatorischen
Gründen ausgefallen oder
nicht gemacht worden. Läuft die Aufnahme?
Ja, die Aufnahme.
Kurzer andere Liedschwürden.
Also ich war letztes
Ich war letzte Woche
am Rustfest in Barcelona. Das war ziemlich cool.
Und mir ist bloß gerade
aufgefallen, deswegen habe ich Swift angesprochen, dass ich
da jemandem gegenüber erwähnt habe, dass ich
einen Podcast betreibe.
Und dass wir
quasi ein halber Swift, ein halber Rust
Podcast sind, so ein gemischtes
Doppel quasi.
Und dementsprechend mir
aufgefallen, ja, wir müssen eigentlich mal, du müsstest mehr über Swift
reden. Dann können wir sagen, wir sind
der deutsche Swift Rust Podcast.
So als
Alleinstellungsmerkmal, wenn wir nicht gerade diese
Interview-Sektion haben, dann ist es einfach bloß unsere
Geschwafel. Was ja auch
witzig sein kann. Aber anyway,
ich
Schweife ab.
Ich wollte über das Rust-Fest reden.
Es war in Barcelona.
Es ging von Samstag bis Dienstag.
Es sind immer zwei Tage Vorträge und Workshops.
Und dann zwei Tage Impel Days.
Das ist cool.
Ja, Impel Days vor allem, weil es halt
ein Keyword in Rust ist.
Und ich war diesmal mit meinem Kumpel Gibber da.
Den hatte ich ja nicht gefragt, aber heute vorbeikommen wir,
aber er konnte leider nicht.
Und wir sind schon ein paar Tage vorher hin,
haben ein bisschen Tourismus gemacht und haben uns ein bisschen
die Sacrada Familie angeguckt.
Die Baustelle?
Die Baustelle, aber es ist schon erstaunlich viel fertig.
Also das müssen eigentlich nur noch ein paar Türmchen
oben drauf und eine Seite ran.
Okay, ich frage, ob ich das letzte Mal vor neun Jahren oder so.
Ja, jetzt mittlerweile ist die,
hast du ein komplett fertiges inneres
Kirchenschiff und wir waren auf dem Turm hoch,
haben dafür Geld bezahlt,
was dann natürlich jetzt unlauter zum Bau von Kirchen verwendet wird, aber na gut.
Es sieht vor allem ziemlich geil aus, dadurch, dass wir im November 12 Uhr mittags in dem Kirchenschiff war,
stand die Sonne schön tief und fiel 12 Uhr mittags genau durch die Seite, durch so ein Fenster rein.
Das Geile sind einfach diese, also die Kirchenfenster sind einfach bloß abstrakte kleine Schindeln,
Das sind keine Motive wirklich, aber es setzt sich so ein Muster vor, dass das quasi auf einer Seite so ein Regenbogenmuster ergibt.
So ein bisschen von Rot nach Blau.
Und das hat sich so richtig in diesen Raum rein projiziert.
Kann ich dir mal ein Bild zeigen nachher, das sieht zumindest ziemlich geil aus.
Wir waren einen Tag in Girona, das ist irgendwie 45 Minuten mit dem Schnellzug weg.
Dort fahren Schnellzüge durchweg 200 kmh.
Das kriegst du in Deutschland nicht hin.
Das war also so weit weg wie Berlin von hier.
Plus, dass du halt von hier nach Berlin
nicht am Stück 200 kmh fährst.
Da gab es eine relativ
coole Altstadt.
coole Altstadt. Da wurden einige Szenen
von Game of Thrones gedreht.
Da haben wir uns dann irgendwie so Stellen, die wir
aus der Serie kennen angeguckt.
Aber die Konferenz selber war auch ziemlich cool.
Es hat sich überschnitten mit dem
1.39er Release der Sprache.
Und seit dieser Version ist
Async-Away-Syntax stabil.
schon uns gepackt. Das ist sehr relevant.
Und ich werde da
nächste Woche am
27. machen wir ein Rust-Meetup.
Dann werde ich da noch ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen,
so als Hands-on. Ich habe selber noch nicht
sonderlich viel damit rumgespielt, aber es hat
ein paar interessante Auswirkungen.
Also was mich
in...
Wenn ich es jetzt vergleichen würde mit
JavaScript Async Await,
es ist schon ein Stückchen anders.
Okay, inwiefern?
Sobald du an eine Funktion in JavaScript Async heranschreibst, ist eigentlich nichts passiert.
Das Einzige, was dir Async in JavaScript an einer Funktion macht, ist, dass du darin dann await benutzen darfst.
Du kannst aus einer Async-Funktion in JavaScript immer noch synchron rausreturnen.
Du kannst einfach was returnen.
Das ist eine Backwards-Comparability-Ding.
Keine Ahnung.
Du kannst aus einer Async-Funktion einfach return sagen und was du dann rausgibst, ist kein Promise.
Okay. Du kannst
was mit await return, dann gibst du
ein Promise raus. Das ist ein bisschen komisch. Du kannst
dir einen Fuß schießen.
Dafür musst du in
in TypeScript
aber sobald du Async davor schreibst, hinten
trotzdem Promise reinschreiben.
Auch wenn das nicht unbedingt ein Promise ist.
Irgendwann ist es konsistent.
Es ist
trotzdem weird. Ja, ich verstehe.
Und in Rust ist es allerdings so, du hast
immer noch deine Funktion, du hast deinen
Return-Typen nach hinten raus.
I32-String, irgend sowas.
Und sobald du Async davor schreibst,
bleibt der immer noch dastehen.
Aber ist dann ein Future
mit dem Output.
So wie es sein sollte.
So sollte das sein.
Genau. Denkt man sich so, ist jetzt cool.
Also ich gebe da was raus, aber es ist halt trotzdem
ich könnte das hinschreiben
mit dem Future.
Aber eigentlich macht dieses Async
davor nur, dass du...
Das ist quasi andersrum.
Die Funktion selber ist nicht mehr special,
sie kann special sein, aber du kannst auch eine Funktion schreiben,
die ein Future
in Rust zurückgibt,
ohne
dass die Funktion selber async ist.
Ist doch schön, wenn die
Datentypen halt da sind und zugänglich sind. Warum nicht?
Genau. Ich empfehle an dieser Stelle
einen von den
Talks von unserem
vergangenen Gast Florian Gilcher, der
in Berlin seine Firma
Ferris Systems hat, die
ganz viele Rust-Twecks vorantreiben.
die haben Async-STD entwickelt.
Async-STD ist quasi
ein Schirm für die gesamte
Rust-Standard-Bibliothek Async.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Du kannst dann also Sachen machen, die normalerweise blockieren würden,
wenn sie sich die Datei aufmachen, kannst du dann plötzlich
check, so muss das ja
erwarten. Genau.
Das mit dem, die Funktionen
gibt plötzlich ein Future
zurück, obwohl das hinten kein Future
dran steht, wenn es Async davor stehen hat.
Hat aber auch den Effekt, ich
hab mich dann zu
Ich habe dann Kontakt mit,
ich glaube, sein Name ist ausgesprochen,
Joshua Woods aufgenommen,
der auch beim Rustfest war.
Der hat dieses Romeo losgetreten.
Das ist Romeo?
Romeo ist ein Async-Await-benutzender
Fork von Tokio gewesen.
Und entwickelt auch an Tide
einem der
fünf, sechs Rust-Fest-Frameworks mit.
Ich habe gesagt, ich möchte bei Tide mal wieder mithelfen.
Ich habe am letzten Rustfest schon ein bisschen mitgehackt.
Ich würde gerne jetzt auch was machen.
Und er sagt mir, ja, ich habe hier diese Funktion geschrieben
und die kompilieren einfach nichts und ich verstehe es nicht.
Der macht das und das
und die Fehlermeldung ist so und das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Vielleicht kannst du da mal drauf gucken.
Ich habe eine halbe Stunde drauf geguckt und dann ist mir aufgefallen,
da steht der Zyk davor.
Machen wir das mal weg.
Kompiliert plötzlich.
Weil die Fehlermeldung war unlesbar,
weil die Fehlermeldungen in dem Bereich noch nicht wirklich gut sind
in der Version.
Aber die Fehlermeldung war, wenn du genau drauf geguckt hast,
ich erwarte,
dass du hier ein Objekt so und so zurückgibst.
Ich kriege aber ein Future vom Objekt so und so zurück.
Insofern, selbst er, der relativ viel damit schon im letzten Jahr gemacht hat,
hat diese Fehlermeldung nicht auf Anhieb gerafft.
Da ist noch Optimierungspotenzial.
Ja, bei Fehlermeldungen sind wir das eine.
Die könnten immer besser sein.
Da kann man auch aktuell recht gut in der aktuellen Swift-Welt,
also wenn du mit Swift-UI-Zuip-Bedingungen machst,
da wo der Swift-Compiler halt so wirklich an seine Grenzen mitkommt,
dass die Fehlermeldungen teilweise halt überhaupt
nicht zu dem passen, was du da gerade
falsch gemacht hast. Die es dann in einer ganz anderen
Zeile hat, sagt er einfach hier, dass sie oben ist,
Invalide. Ja, nee, das hat einfach nichts damit zu tun.
Der Compiler kommt mit seinem Typechecking
halt einfach nicht hinterher und versteht nicht,
was hier falsch läuft. Aber gut,
sowas hat man halt immer.
Sprachen
beziehungsweise Compiler scheitern immer an
sehr guten
Diagnostics, die man halt ausgeben kann.
Und das ist halt immer
das, was...
Ist ja auch was, was Compiler erst sehr spät gelernt haben, wenn du mal überlegst, wie GCC-Fehlermeldungen 30 Jahre lang aussahen.
Ja, mein Favorit ist immer noch Latex mit Fehlerteile 0, figure it out, fuck you.
Also zumindest Fehlermeldungen von C++ und C-Compilern sind traditionell fürchterlich gewesen.
Da ist eigentlich der Anspruch, den wir haben an Compiler,
von dem gerade von Rust selber eigentlich sehr...
Rust und Elm sind da sehr bekannt für,
fantastische Fehlermeldungen auszugeben.
So, und insofern sind wir einfach verwöhnt, möchte ich behaupten.
Ja, ich meine, klar, wenn du in dem Ökosystem drinsteckst,
wo du quasi anhand von Fehlermeldungen das Programmieren lernen kannst,
weil der Compiler dir sagt, was hier syntaktisch falsch ist,
wie das eigentlich aussehen müsste,
was du jetzt eigentlich hier versuchst,
das ist quasi wie ein modernes Clippy.
Genau.
Plus in gut.
Und es gibt Clippy.
Das meinte ich nicht.
Aber apropos fürchterliche
Fehlermeldungen.
Ich habe
einen gemeinsamen Bekannten von uns
in Natura getroffen.
In Barcelona. Ach, ich weiß sogar,
wie du meinst. Den Nikolaj Vasquez,
der ein halbes Jahr in Dresden gewohnt hat,
ohne dass wir ihn getroffen haben.
Und den wir
unwissentlich im letzten
Podcast mit seiner Arbeit
erwähnt haben, nämlich der ist der
Entwickler von
Swift Bind Gen.
Ja, das war es, stimmt.
Sehr cool.
Cooler Typ, hat eine Menge zu erzählen
und
hat zum Beispiel auch
ein Lightning Talk
über Static Assertions
gehalten. Und Static
Assertions sind wirklich sehr abgefahrene
Assertions, die dir zum Beispiel
erlauben zu validieren, dass ein Typ,
den du reingibst, dieses
erfüllt oder dass er dieses
alle diese, aber nicht
dieses Trade erfüllt oder sowas.
Also sowas muss der Compiler ja eh schon machen.
Ja, aber du kannst noch weitere
Assertions machen. Das geht wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel
tiefer. Du kannst direkt eine Aussage
treffen, hier dieser Typ
implementiert von diesen fünf Trades nur eins
zum Beispiel. Das ist jetzt eine ausgedachte Sache.
Ich habe es selber noch nicht benutzt. Mir fällt auch nicht wirklich ein Use Case
dafür ein, aber das ist was, was ein
logischer Ausdruck, den dir die Sprache
so per se erstmal nicht gibt. Interessant.
Okay.
Aber ich dachte, Rusty-Tip-System ist schon
Turing-vollständig. Ja, das
beweist es ja auch.
Siehst als Helfer-Library
dafür an, sonst müsstest du es per Hand schreiben.
Klingt ja so, dass es sich
coole Anwendungsfälle haben. Klingt erstmal
ziemlich geil, bis er dir dann den Code, aus dem
es basiert, zeigt, was er bei diesem
Lightning-Talk natürlich gemacht hat.
Und seine Assertions haben halt
den Effekt, dass
die Assertion entweder
durchläuft, also entweder
true ausgibt, das heißt es kompiliert
oder
deine Assertion ist nicht erfüllt
und dann kompiliert es mit einem total hässlichen
Fehler, weil du es nicht anders
ausdrücken kannst momentan. Also du kannst nicht sagen
kompiliere nicht mit dieser
Fehlermeldung, das kannst du nicht ausdrücken, aber
du kannst das Assert so schreiben,
dass du
damit Code erzeugst, der nur dann
kompilierbar ist,
wenn deine Assertion
erfüllt ist und ansonsten halt nicht
kompilierbaren Code erzeugt.
Spaß mit Fehlermeldung hatte ich ja auch bei meinem Projekt bei Apple. Das war ja quasi genau, dass Fehlermeldungen so strukturieren bzw. die Fehler, die du halt programmatisch irgendwie rausrechnest, so in Worte fassen, dass die halt überhaupt Sinn ergeben.
Und der Nutzer hat das quasi, wir haben es mal als Actionable Diagnostics bezeichnet, dass du halt wirklich weißt, was du tun kannst als Nutzer, dem diese Meldung präsentiert wird.
Wie ist so eine Fehlermeldung eigentlich
dargestellt
intern? Ich meine, in Rust
gibt es ja mittlerweile wirklich dieses Fix-Tool,
wo jede Fehlermeldung quasi
in den Fix mitliefert mittlerweile, dass du sagst,
wenn du das und das da oben hinst,
pass auf, ich kann das für dich machen und dann kannst du
mit Rust fix oder mit Cargo
fix direkt deine Fehlermeldung
fixen lassen. Okay, also ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher,
wie die Struktur davon ausschaute. Ich glaube,
das war auch irgendwas, das String-basiert ist am Ende, weil
das andere Tools auch machen können, die du
mit einbindest in Xcode, aber du hast
auch die Möglichkeit, solche Fixits heißen, die da
mit zu liefern, die du dann
einfach als Nutzer der IDE
direkt draufschmeißen kannst.
Was natürlich praktisch ist,
es gibt auch den Fix-All-Issues-Button in Xcode,
der einfach alle Fixits appelliert,
aber den nutze
ich ungern, beziehungsweise nie, weil
man hat auch diesen
einen Moment, also es gibt selten mal diesen
Fall, aber der gibt es immer wieder,
dass du irgendwie von Xcode hier
eine Fehlermeldung hast, von wegen hier,
du hast irgendwelchen Generics-Fu gemacht,
das kann ich hier nicht auflösen, ersetzt mal
das durch das. Okay.
Ah, nee, warte, jetzt ist es auch falsch. Ersetzt mal
das wieder durch das ursprüngliche. Und dann
ist es halt so ein Fixed-Kreis.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie es deshalb noch nicht automatisiert,
weil es irgendwie so endlos schleift. Ja, sowas willst du halt
glaube ich auch nicht automatisieren. Also
Entwickler einen Code unter dem Arsch wegreißen,
willst du maximal für das Formatting,
aber nicht für wirklich inhaltliche Änderungen.
Naja, es gibt, wie gesagt, Clippy-Sachen
in Rust,
kannst du fast mittlerweile alle
automatisch fixen lassen.
Klippi ist ein Linter.
Klippi ist ein Rust-Linter, der dir
ziemlich krasse Sachen anzeigt.
Klippi macht auch so ein bisschen
Static Analysis gleich mit, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, oder?
Static Analysis macht Klippi
auch so ein bisschen mit.
Das ist Static Analysis.
Das ist alles von der...
Also es sind keine Fehler,
sondern es sind Lints.
Mach das mal nicht, weil das
nicht performant ist.
machen wir das nicht, weil es irgendwie
so und so besser geht.
Das ist alles aus der Kategorie, das kannst du schon so
machen, ist dann halt kacke.
Okay, gute Kategorie.
Ich suche gerade mal die Webseite dazu raus, weil
da gibt es eine Liste, ah hier, hier.
Da gibt es eine Liste mit allen
Lins
und
die sind,
da gibt es Gruppen,
Style, Complexity, Correctness,
Performance,
Deprecated, dann gibt es noch
Sachen, die noch nicht... Da gibt es eine Nursery
Group, weil manche Lins noch nicht
ausgereift sind. Und dann gibt es noch Pedantic.
Da kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel
in dem Kommandozeilen-Tool sagen
Cargo Clippy Worn Pedantic.
Dann sagt ihr dir wirklich...
Also es ist wirklich Pedantic.
Was ist da so ein Beispiel so drin in der Pedantischen
Kategorie? Ich mach mal ein einfaches
Beispiel. Ich sag mal alle aus.
Mach dir mal Style. Mal ein einfaches
Style-Beispiel, damit wir ein Bild dafür bekommen.
Blacklisted Name ist ein
schönes Beispiel. War Gilbert neulich vorgegangen.
Du nennst eine Variable foo.
Sagt er dir, foo is a blacklisted name.
Das ist fair.
Dann gibt es compare 0.
Wenn du eine Variable mit
is gleich ist gleich mit 0 vergleichst,
mach das nicht.
Da gibt es eine Methode für,
die heißt is 0.
It is easier and more readable
to use the inherent is 0.
Das ist auch ein Ding,
was ich bei Swiftend öfter mal sehe,
wenn du den Count von einem Array
mit 0 der Teilhabe über das empty prüfen.
Genau, das gleiche gibt es ja auch.
da gibt es, bitte benutze
die isEmpty-Methode
und so weiter und so fort.
Hier leere Loops.
Es gibt eine Loop-Syntax in Rust,
die wirklich endlos Loop produziert.
Das ist Loop und dann Block.
Und eigentlich müsste das
eher auch produzieren, finde ich.
Wenn du diesen Code hier schreibst,
Loop, geschweifte Klammer auf, zu,
dann kommst du dann wieder raus.
So schick kannst du direkt den Thread abschieben.
Das war Style.
Dann gibt es halt so schicke Sachen wie
Perf, Performance, da sind ganz viele Sachen
dabei, wie wenn du
ein Unwrap-Or machst,
kannst du da zum Beispiel
oder ein Expect-Or, klassischer Fall,
ich habe ein Optional
und ich sage Expect.
Expect sagt, ist dasselbe wie Unwrap, also flieg
mir um die Ohren. Bei Expect kannst du
allerdings einen eigenen Text angeben.
Jetzt kannst du allerdings
da nur statische Strings reingeben.
Du kannst aber auch
ein Format-Makro reingeben
und dann einen Format-String erzeugen und dann
mit irgendwelchen Variablen ausführen.
Dann sagt dir Clippy, das kannst du
schon so machen, aber dein
dynamischer Format-String wird erzeugt,
egal ob du in dieses Expect reinläufst
oder nicht. Deswegen gibt es
dann ein Expect
or Else, was
ein Lambda annimmt. Da schreibst
du dasselbe rein mit zwei Pipes davor
und dann plötzlich wird es nur ausgeführt, wenn du
wirklich dahin gehst.
Spart dir eine Allokation und so Kleinigkeiten. Und Pedantic
ist dann
Pedantic sind dann Sachen wie
du hast ein
Empty Inam.
Inam ohne Inhalt.
Du hast irgendwie
bestimmte Sachen
Markdown nicht richtig benannt.
Genau, wenn er nämlich Code
in Dokumentaren
in Dokumentaren,
wenn er Referenzen auf Variablen
oder Typen findet, hakt er dir an,
da müssen Backtext drum rum.
Geil. Oh, ist wirklich cool.
if not else
hakt er dir an. Das heißt, wenn du
ein if Ausrufezeichen irgendwas
und ein else hast, dann sagt er dir,
schreib das doch andersrum.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Da gibt es relativ viel und das meiste
ist per default allowed.
Und bei Clippy, das habe ich nur irgendwann
zum Spaß mal probiert, kannst du halt sagen
cargo clippy
fix pedantic.
Und dann passiert
sehr viel in deinem Code.
Und da gibt es halt manchmal Sachen, die ein bisschen kaputt sind.
Es gibt zum Beispiel die Annotation
Must Use an bestimmten Typen
oder an Funktionen.
Ich glaube an Funktionen. Wenn eine Funktion was zurückgibt
und du benutzt das nicht,
gibt es eine Warning,
wenn da Must Use dran steht.
Must Use ist Syntax?
Must Use ist ein Attribut.
Also ein hier
Hashtag in Klammern
oben drüber.
Das steht zum Beispiel an...
Und was per Default ist,
wenn du den Return-Wert einfach ignore,
Ja, genau, wenn ich jetzt eine Funktion aufrufe,
die ein Result zurückgibt und ich benutze das Result
nicht. Dann hast du klassischen Schrodingers
Result-File. Du weißt ja
nicht, ob es schiefgegangen ist oder nicht, bis du nicht das
Result aufmachst. Wenn du das Result
nicht benutzt, da steht per default must
use dran.
Zwift hat das genau andersrum. Zwift hat so ein Attribut
für Funktionen, der heißt discardable result, dann
warnt dir der Compiler nicht, wenn du den Result,
muss ja kein Result-Typ sein, aber wenn du den Result der Funktion
nicht benutzt. Genau, und in Rust sieht das
so aus, das ist da per default dran.
Und du kannst das Attribut dran schreiben,
allow unused oder sowas.
Unused result oder sowas.
Zumindest Clippy sagt dann, oh, du könntest hier
must use dran schreiben und du könntest hier must use dran schreiben.
Der hatte dann irgendeinen Link, der gesagt hat,
du hast da einen Rückgabe wert, lass uns da mal must use
dran schreiben, nachher benutzt das jemand nicht.
So, und dann haben wir
wirklich, da war wirklich fast jede
Funktion in meinem Code angefasst und
Clippy hatte überall must use drin geschrieben.
Ich hab mir gedacht, fuck.
Die eine Regel muss man vielleicht nicht unbedingt...
Die muss man, also, ich würde dann
neben Pedantic noch eine Regel anfangen,
die hilarious heißt oder sowas.
Es ist ja pedantisch, wenn du das annotieren kannst
und vielleicht teilweise auch solltest.
Pedantisch ist ja dann wirklich der Fall für,
du machst alles explizit, was explizit sein kann
und du bist hier mal voll durch.
Ich hatte vor zwei oder drei Rustfesten
mal in so einem Clippy-Workshop einen eigenen
Lins geschrieben, der dir
ankreidet, wenn du
Parameter vom Typ bool
in deinen Funktionen nimmst. Achso, weil du der
Verfechter warst, dass man dafür E-Nams machen sollte?
Genau, weil das einfach eine scheiß API ist.
Ja, finde ich,
man sollte drüber nachdenken, aber das kann man nicht global
gleich so sagen. Also bei Swift ist es glaube ich
nicht so wild, weil deine Swift
Funktionssyntax ein bisschen anders
spricht. Da schreibst du ja ran, wie das Ding heißt
und dann ergibt das True-False plötzlich Sinn.
Wenn ich eine Funktion habe, die fünf Sachen annimmt
und davon sind
zwei Bool
und wenn ich die aus Versehen verwechsel
und da steht dann einfach True-True
oder True-False und ich false-True
und es ist dann völlig kaputt, das ist ein scheiß API.
Benannte Funktionsargumente sind so Dinge,
warum gibt es das nicht überall?
Das ist so toll.
In vielen IDEs machen die das ja mit.
Die ganzen JetPrint-Sachen, die schreiben die dir einfach so mit rein.
Das finde ich schon echt ein praktisches Feature,
aber das ist einfach so ein tolles Feature.
Das macht der Rust-Analyzer jetzt.
Rust-Analyzer ist ein Ersatz
für die
Integration, die bisherige
Integration für Rust in VS Code.
Und zwar
für RLS,
nicht RLS selber,
der Rust-Language-Server doch irgendwie schon.
Ach, ist das so ein Teil davon, oder was?
Wenn du ein VS Code mit
Rust ausstattest, laufender
RLS, der Rust-Language-Server,
der benutzt Racer,
dann benutzt er, glaube ich,
nochmal einzelnen Racer
und das ist alles unabhängig vom Server,
unabhängig vom Compiler
bereits irgendwie seit
fünf Jahren da und wird unabhängig vom...
Der Racer ist ja schon noch älter als der RLS gewesen.
Genau. Und das hat jetzt Ferris Systems, also Florians Bude, auch nochmal neu gebaut. Und es funktioniert richtig gut.
Es ist richtig nice. Also dein Code läuft im Hintergrund. Es ist immer noch ein bisschen langsam manchmal. Aber du hast anständige Fehlermeldungen direkt am Code dran.
Du hast dieses Problems- und Warnings-Panel in VS Code ist anständig populiert.
Das Outline ist anständig populiert.
Du siehst jetzt in deiner Ansicht wirklich Typen und dann steht da ein Impelblock für das, Impelblock für das.
Kannst du draufklicken, ist super geil.
Und was sie jetzt seit dem letzten Update auch noch machen, ist, dass sie dir die inferierten Typen,
wenn sie eine bestimmte Länge nicht überschreiten, an Variablen heranschreiben.
Das heißt, ihr schreibst let.
Foo ist gleich Rückgabewert von irgendwas.
Steht nirgendwo, was für ein Typ dieses Ding zurückgibt.
Blendet es dir an der Stelle ein im Code.
Das ist cool.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Also es macht alles Riesenfortschritte.
Genau.
Ich habe einen Workshop mitgemacht,
der wieder von einem der G-Streamer-Entwickler gehostet wurde.
Oder bereitet wurde.
Das letzte Mal haben wir einen GTK WebRTC-Client gebaut.
Dieses Mal haben wir
einen G-Streamer
WebRTC-Server gebaut,
wo du mit einer Webseite dich drauf
verbinden konntest.
Das hat dann zum Signaling
eine Websocket-Library verwendet,
die ziemlich schick und schlank ist.
Das ist ziemlich nice. Also das ist eine ganze Menge,
gerade dieser gesamte Web-Bereich,
da passiert gerade relativ viel in der Rust-Welt.
Ich wollte jetzt auf dem Rust-Fest ein bisschen
an bestimmten Lips spielen, da tat es dann
so ein bisschen weh, weil gerade dadurch,
dass jetzt Ace and Go Wait
so ein Tag stabil geworden ist,
waren vielen Lips noch sehr viel
Bewegung, sodass zum Beispiel
Tide, womit ich spielen wollte, der hat der Master
überhaupt nicht gebaut bis letzte Woche
und der Hauptmain-Trainer
hat jetzt irgendwie heute
einen Tweet rausgehauen, dass wir wohl nächste Woche
mal wieder einen neuen Release machen wollen.
Da kannst du dann so langsam damit arbeiten.
Aber ja, es war echt cool.
Ich kann jedem auch
die Talks empfehlen, die da
gehalten wurden. Es gab einige zum Thema Ace and Go Wait,
und wie es funktioniert. Gibt es die online?
Wahrscheinlich, oder? Gibt es online. Einfach
Rustfest auf YouTube so.
Zum Beispiel von einem Google-Fuchsia-Entwickler.
Ah. The Life of an
AsyncFN.
Wenn du jetzt eine Funktion mit
AsyncAwait in Rust schreibst, auf was für State
Machines bildet das intern ab? Und dann hat er gesagt,
naja, wir könnten uns jetzt quasi vorstellen, diese Funktion
beinhaltet,
stellt dieses, hat
dieses Inam als State Machine
und dann gibt es, an jedem Punkt
hat er geheilitet, wo ein Await steht.
Das ist quasi ein neuer State. Und dann wandert
unsere Co-Routine,
die es nicht wirklich ist, unsere Async-FN,
von einem Zustand in den nächsten.
Und dann, naja, eigentlich bräuchten wir
den Stack-Frame gar nicht für die gesamte
Größe, weil diese und diese Variablen zum Beispiel
nie gleichzeitig da sind. Da gibt es jetzt eine Compiler-Optimierung.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt nur noch halb so vier
Speicher und so weiter und so fort.
Und halt erwähnt, wie sie es in Fuchsia
verwenden und dass sie irgendwie ein bisschen bessere
Performance-Garantien haben als C++.
Und das ist ein ziemlich cooler Vortrag.
Genere Fuchs ja bespannt, wenn da mal mehr
rauskommt. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was da passiert.
Auf jeden Fall. Die scheinen aber auch sehr stark
auf Rust zu setzen an der Stelle.
Ich finde das heiß.
Du hast ja noch ein paar andere Sachen zum Rustfest
aufgeschrieben. Neue Messenger, neue...
Oh ja, was mir ein bisschen auf den Sack ging, ist,
ich habe jetzt noch einen neuen Messenger installiert.
Der Nikolai hatte
einen Tag vorm Rustfest getwittert,
ey, ich habe mal diesen Discord-Raum
aufgemacht. Ja, nicht Discord.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, gut, okay,
dann installiere ich mir jetzt mal Discord und ich bin da
ehrlich gesagt, so ein bisschen
da rein
gesaugt wurden, weil die gesamte Rust-Community
auch Discord verwendet,
anstatt Slack. Das heißt, ich habe meinen Account,
ich hatte mir dieses eine,
das Schöne gegenüber Slack ist, dass du
mit einem Account hier mehrere solche Gruppen
mitzunehmen kannst.
Der Client ist auch erstaunlich gut abgerundet, finde ich.
Der Client funktioniert schön und
ich bin jetzt in dem Rustlang
Discord, in dem Rustfest Discord
und in dem Async Rust Discord
und
liest dann immer was. Also das ist wirklich das, wo
die Arbeitsgruppen ihre Arbeit
koordinieren. Macht auch vieles damit zu
lesen, wenn du wirklich mal einsteigen willst. Ich hätte mir nicht vorgenommen,
ein bisschen mehr mitzumachen, tatsächlich aktiv.
Zumindest habe ich jetzt ein Messenger mehr
auf meinem Handy oder auf meinem
Rechner. Ich mache jetzt auf meinem
PC zu Hause zurzeit parallel
Signal,
Riot, Discord
und Slack an. Schon scheiße, oder?
Es ist gut, dass ich mir den mit 32
Gigabyte speichert.
Tja, vielleicht kann
Matrix mit Bridges das ja besser erschlagen.
Hoffentlich, hoffentlich.
Eine Empfehlung, die ich an dieser Stelle
noch machen kann, wäre...
Wir haben übrigens einen akonomisierbaren Discord.
Echt jetzt?
Ich habe mich gerade mal angemeldet, seit Ewigkeiten.
Anscheinend habe ich das mal irgendwann aufgemacht.
Geht da nicht rein.
Bitte geht da nicht rein, wenn wir gehen zu Riot.
Wer jetzt nicht genug von meinem
Rust-Geprabbel hat, dem kann ich
noch einen neuen Podcast empfehlen.
Und zwar hat ja Chris Kreitschow mit dem New Rustation Podcast vor ein paar Monaten aufgehört und den eingestellt.
Und um diese Lücke zu füllen, haben zwei Jungs aus Boston.
Einer davon ist sogar auf dem Rustfest gewesen.
Ich habe auch bloß von dem Podcast gehört, weil ich den Typen, der den macht, im Starbucks getroffen habe.
Witzig.
Und der heißt Rustation Station.
Toller Name.
Ja, Naming Things ist hart.
Ist aber ein ziemlich cool gemachter Podcast.
Die machen eine Folge
pro Release mindestens,
wo sie über die Release Notes drüber gehen
und das erklären. Und zwischendurch haben sie
bereits mehrere Interview-Folgen gemacht,
unter anderem mit dem Entwickler von
Rooma, diesem
Matrix-Hop-Server.
Genau, also wenn du mit dem ein Interview
holen willst,
rustation-station.org
Ist in Jonas schon drin.
Genau.
das war mein
Rustfest Trip Report, wenn mir nicht
nachher noch andere Sachen einfallen zu dem Thema.
Nice.
Sehr, sehr cool. Neuer Podcast ist immer gut.
Krieg mal reinhören.
Apropos
Konferenzen, GitHub hatte ja auch
irgendwie GitHub Universe jetzt letzte Woche
oder so. Stimmt.
Hast du dir da irgendwelche Vorträge angehört?
Ich hab bloß mal in die
Keynote-Presentation ein bisschen mit reingehört,
wo sie ein bisschen was vorgestellt haben.
Unter anderem haben sie ja Actions und die Package-Registry
jetzt aus der Beta rausgeschoben.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt stabil zu benutzen?
Also stabil, keine Ahnung,
aber es ist zumindest für jeden direkt zu benutzen.
Also kein Beta-Feature mehr.
Genau.
Also Actions hatten wir ja das letzte Mal schon erwähnt,
aber wir haben es nicht geschafft, beide damit rumzuspielen.
Naja, wir haben halt schon letztes Mal damit rumgespielt.
Ich weiß nicht, was du gemacht hast.
Also ich sehe zumindest, wenn ich mir ein paar Rust-Projekte angucke,
die benutzen für ihre CI bereits GitHub-Actions.
Da gibt es dann einfach oben einen Actions-Tab
und dann siehst du die letzten Builds
und sowas. Das ist ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so
hübsch wie bei Travis.
Das finde ich noch schöner. Ich habe mir auch, wie gesagt,
so Sachen gewünscht, wie
mich automatisch als Reviewer hinzufügen
bei meinen eigenen Repos.
Aber Travis ist super lahm immer gewesen
und gefühlt ja auch schon jetzt länger tot.
Travis ist tot? Die wurden noch gekauft
und hieß doch, wird bald irgendwie vielleicht
eingestellt, aber das ist schon drei Jahre her oder so.
Ich meine, so eine CI
mit einem kostenlosen
Modell zu betreiben, ist halt
Machst Remote Code Execution as a Service.
Genau.
Ist halt,
ja, da kann halt viel passieren.
Ja, also man musste sich natürlich sicherlich irgendwie
absichern, aber du zahlst
halt, also Trevers war ja auch gesponsert
die ganze Zeit von irgendwelchen
großen Geldgebern
und das war's,
naja, ich weiß nicht, was da,
wie man da einen großen Business drum macht.
Die hatten halt noch Trevers angeboten
als privates CI für
nicht öffentliche Dinge, aber da hat sich
eh jeder, der es ernst meint, irgendwie was
anderes genommen. Ob das jetzt
irgendwie was Spezifischeres ist, wie
keine Ahnung,
wie Plattformen wie Bitrise, wenn du halt irgendwelche Apps
machen möchtest, oder ob du deine
eigenen Jenkins hostest, das eh
darüber alles läuft. Ich finde Jenkins gar nicht mal so schlimm.
Hast du schon mal eins?
Wir nutzen ja auch auf Arbeit.
Es funktioniert wunderbar,
die UI ist halt ein bisschen schrecklich, aber
ich meine... Ja, es geht.
Das ist nicht schön, aber es geht.
Gerade seitdem es Jenkins-Files gibt.
Aber die sind irgendwie,
wenn du genau drüber nachdenkst,
ist es ein Jenkins-File,
eine DSL auf Basis einer DSL,
auf Basis von irgendeiner anderen DSL.
Sind die immer in Groovy geschrieben,
oder ist das nur bei uns so?
Die sind, glaube ich, in Groovy.
Ja, das ist eine DSL auf Groovy-Basis, glaube ich.
Das finde ich geil.
Ich habe nie aktiv Groovy gesehen, außer dort.
Also ich weiß ja, dass Groovy existiert,
aber ich finde das mega cool.
Es ist wahrscheinlich gerade bei so
Build-Skripten sinnvoller, was
zu haben, was ein bisschen ausführbar ist
als eine rein deklarative Sprache,
schätze ich mal. Es gibt keine rein deklarativen
Sprachen, die werden alle irgendwann ausführbar.
Ist
JSON eine deklarativ? Noch.
Achso. Nicht mehr lange.
Das ist eine Frage der Zeit.
Von einer deklarativen Sprache zu einer
fullblauen Programmiersprache. Das ist Jamel ja auch so.
Jamel ist Jamel-Turing
vollständig? Hattest du da nicht mal was zu gehabt?
Also YAML kann sehr viel mehr, als du denkst,
aber alles nur
aus dem Kontext dieser
YAML kann
keine eigenen Dateien aufmachen.
XML kann Dateien aufmachen.
Aber YAML kann
keine Dateien aufmachen.
Achso, kann man noch was zu GitHub?
Bevor ich da ein Thema wechsle.
Ja, bei denen ist gerade Universe.
Die hatten GitHub Mobile noch angekündigt, was ich cool finde.
Das ist ja eine mobile App.
Für iOS aber, oder?
Ich dachte auch Android.
Aber die sind auf beiden Plattformen in Beta,
die kriegst du noch nicht im Store.
Ich habe den Testplatte-Bild mal
für iOS installiert. Funktioniert ganz gut.
Ich habe vorher immer die App GitHub
benutzt. Das ist der Typ, der die entwickelt hat,
ist auch zu GitHub und hat jetzt das GitHub Mobile
mitentwickelt. Ich muss sagen, GitHub Mobile
ist erstaunlich schwer zu googeln oder zu
DuckDuckGoan, weil ich finde es halt alles
mögliche, was Mobile heißt, auf GitHub.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ich finde es ganz schön, vor allem, wenn man schnell
Issues aufmachen kann und Notifications lesen.
Mehr würde ich auf Mobile gar nicht machen.
Das stimmt.
Sie haben immer noch den Nachteil, dass sie eine Notification
anklicken, die halt also gelesen markiert.
Das finde ich in der WebUI.
Sie hatten ja früher schon mal eine eigene App,
die sie dann deprecated haben.
GitHub hatte nie eine offizielle App.
Nicht? Aber es gab so ein paar
GitHub-Apps bereits, die allerdings irgendwann
nicht mehr unterstützt wurden, weil GitHub
einfach keine stabile API unterstützt hat.
Sie haben halt ihre GraphQL-API.
Darauf kannst du halt beliebig aufsetzen, was ja ganz cool ist.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich finde aber nur schön, dass es existiert, weil ich mir das
auf meinem Homescreen eh immer gewünscht habe.
Die hatten noch ein paar andere Sachen an den Kündigungen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was da noch alles war, aber gerade
Actions, Package-Adjusty
und GitHub Mobile waren so, glaube ich, die großen
Sachen. Sie haben ein paar, gefühlt immer so Redesigns,
Notification, UI in der Webseite, da hat
jetzt eine neue Ansicht.
Aber finde ich auch nicht so prickelnd, aber
naja, ist jetzt nicht so
das, was
ich jetzt super spannend finde. Da war Mobile und
Actions schon mehr.
Also mir würde es hauptsächlich reichen, wenn ich irgendwie sehe,
dass es neue Tickets, oder wenn ich einfach
Auflistung meiner
Tickets, meiner Issues sehe
und ob mir da jemand drauf antwortet oder nicht.
Was mich ehrlich gesagt...
Da sind ja Notifications drin.
Was mich ehrlich gesagt bei GitHub stört, ist,
dass wenn ich,
dass ich keine, zumindest
meines Erachtens nach, keine gute Ansicht
von allen Tickets meiner Repos habe.
Das ist oben, wenn du auf Issues klickst,
auf der Startseite.
Ja, da gibt es, wenn ich auf Issues gehe,
sehe ich Issues, die ich aufgemacht habe.
Siehst du nicht auch alle, die bei dir drin sind?
dann gibt es...
Ach nee, vielleicht auch nicht.
Wenn jemand ein Issue aufmacht, dann sehe ich hier
den blauen Punkt auf der
Glocke und wenn ich es dann gelesen habe,
habe ich nirgendwo mehr eine Referenz dazu.
Jetzt hast du ja alle...
Klick mal auf die Glocke drauf.
Und deswegen habe ich dann festgestellt, dass ich
mich dann mittlerweile selber assignen muss
zu einem Issue, damit ich das
hier in dieser globalen Übersicht
unter Assigned sehe.
Wenn du jetzt in der neuen Ansicht der Notifications bist, dann sieht das ja anders aus.
So, Notifications...
In der neuen Ansicht siehst du ja auch
alle...
Siehst du auch
die gelesenen...
Ach, Notifications slash Beta
ist das.
Da kommt bei mir 404...
Anscheinend ist das ein A-B-Testing-Feature oder so
und du musst warten, bis du dafür den Button kriegst.
Achso, nee, warte, ich muss
irgendwo auf einer Startseite wahrscheinlich
auf den Button drücken.
Anyway, okay, dann gibt es da wohl was.
Aber geil ist,
das halt immer noch nicht, weil die Dinge halt einfach verschwinden
nach unten zeitlich raus und dann sind sie halt auch weg.
Das nennt sich
The Endless Backlog.
Nee, ist alles
unpraktisch, aber gut,
sowas sind doch wahrscheinlich auch halbwegs ungelöste Probleme.
Sind das ungelöste Probleme?
Du hast einfach eine lange Liste und die Liste
wird halt aufgrund der Funktionalität der Liste
so oder so immer länger. Es ist immer ein Endless Backlog.
Du musst deinen Backlog auch
ab und zu mal groomen.
Aus der Liste kannst du keine Dinge rausschmeißen.
Die einzige Alternative ist halt
wirklich die alles designen.
Wie macht denn das GitLab? Wie macht denn das
Bitbuck? Wie macht denn das GitT?
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist nichts, wo dir die
anbieten, also wo dir diese Plattformen
einer Lösung anbieten.
Ja, aber hast du bei GitLab?
Ich glaube, GitLab hat so eine To-Do-Ansicht
extra noch zusätzlich zu Notifications,
wo Dinge drin landen. Achso.
Und ich glaube, da kann man vielleicht so ein bisschen
hilfreicher was finden, aber keine Ahnung.
Ich nutze leider kein GitLab
aktiv. Würde ich gerne,
mache ich nicht.
Also bei Bitbucket sehe ich auch nur die, wo ich als
Reviewer markiert bin. Bitbucket nutze ich gar nicht.
Also wir nutzen es auf der Arbeit, aber ich gehe
auf Bitbucket nur rein, wenn ich aus dem
Jira einen Blinkz in den Pull Request anklick.
Weil ich Bitbucket noch schlimmer als Jira finde
und das heißt schon was. Krass, bei mir ist es
komplett andersrum. Ich benutze unser Bitbucket
und ich mache die Ansicht auf
und gucke, wo gibt es neue Pull Requests
und wo bin ich assigned und ich schaue nie in unser
Jira, weil ich Jira vielleicht nicht finde.
Nee, ich finde Jira zumindest in dem
angepinnten Jira Tab, was ich
offen habe. Ich kann auf Jira,
nee, okay, ich kann nicht alle Jira anschauen.
Das ist viel zu ekelhaft, viel zu groß.
Bei uns ist es vor allem so, dass sich mehrere Teams ein Jira
teilen. Und deswegen ist unser Jira
fürchterlich und übersichtlich. Die ganze Firma teilt sich das Jira.
Nee, ich meine ein Jira-Board.
Also wir haben einen Backlog, wo mehr...
Mehrere Teams? Ja, ja.
Das sind die Teams, die bis vor kurzem ein großes
Team waren. Ach so.
Und dann willst du nicht anfangen, oh, wir ziehen
unser neues Board zurück. Wir haben irgendwelche,
da gibt es ja Präfixe davor, je nachdem, wie das Projekt
heißt. Die haben überhaupt nichts mit dem zu tun, was wir machen.
Ah, alles schrecklich eigentlich.
Das sind aber welche Three-Letter-Acronyms,
die Projekte beschreiben, die es schon gar nicht mehr gibt
oder gar nicht mehr so heißen.
Das ist ehrlich.
Aber ja, das ist halt das Problem von Jira.
Du kannst nicht sagen, ich schiebe das jetzt mal
unter einen neuen Namespace oder so.
Alles ganz schlimm. Du kannst auch von Jira nicht weg,
weil die Hälfte der Arbeit dann weiter gedrackt wird.
Für die Übergangsphase bist du irgendwie, was weiß ich,
wenn wir jetzt entscheiden würden, wir ziehen von
Jira oder von Bitbucket
von selbstgehäußert nach GitHub oder sowas,
dann müsstest du halt doppelte Buchführung machen
für eine Zeit lang, bist du das,
oder einer setzt sich irgendwie drei Tage hin
und schiebt alle Tickets rüber, oder sowas.
Schrittweise
ist da schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Aber gut.
Ach ja, arbeiten ist schwer. Ich hoffe, unsere Arbeitgeber
hören uns nicht zu.
Ja, wo ich gerade noch hinwollte,
wegen XML,
vorletztes Wochenende, glaube ich, war
hier in Dresden das Open Data
Camp 2019, das war jetzt der zweite
Hackathon der Stadt. Cool.
Da habe ich mal mit teilgenommen.
Cool. War ganz witzig.
Die haben gerade viele Geodaten
Das ist ja schick.
Wunderbar.
Die haben da viele
Geodaten mitgebracht.
Sehr viele Sachen.
Aber unter anderem auch wieder Schnittstellen
von der DVB. Und das hat mich am meisten
gereizt. So habe ich da ein bisschen
was an einer
VVO-DVB-App gebastelt,
die ich schon länger mal so haben wollte.
Fand ich jetzt nicht thematisch ganz so passend,
wie die ganzen anderen coolen Projekte, die da waren.
Aber anscheinend fand die Jury es doch mit ganz cool.
Aber da waren so richtig coole Projekte dabei.
Auch andere, auch mit auf DVB-Daten,
die halt die Verspätung live visualisiert haben auf einer Karte.
Da siehst du alle Straßenbahnlinien in Dresden
und welche gerade irgendwo verspätet sind.
Oder auch ganz andere Sachen,
wie, ich glaube, das Gewinnerteam hatte so eine...
Das war das Dumme,
weil die bei der Präsentation nur noch die Teamnamen am Ende gesagt haben
und nicht mehr, was die Projekte waren.
das Team hieß Obstsalat, das weiß ich noch.
Aber ich glaube,
die haben das Projekt gehabt, dass du
quasi sagst, du hast so und so viel Zeit
und bist an dieser Position in der Stadt
und die verbinden da...
Nicht, wo kommst du hin, sondern
was möchtest du sehen? Möchtest du
touristisch was sehen? Möchtest du Thema Zukunftsstadt
was sehen? Möchtest du nachhaltig irgendwas
sehen? Und dann kannst du dir einfach
mal eine Route planen lassen,
hier von Punkt... Ich glaube, Stolpersteine war auch noch
ein Themenbereich, den du auswählen
konntest.
hast du dann direkt eine Route
durch deine Umgebung für die nächsten 60 Minuten
oder wie immer viel Zeit du angegeben hast,
reinrouten lassen.
Fand ich ein ganz cooles Projekt, aber da war auch generell.
Ich meine, da hatte er einen Geobezug.
Da gab es echt ein paar spannende, tolle Dinge,
die hoffentlich bald mal mit
auf der Dresden-Seite stehen. Das haben sie bisher
noch nicht geschafft. Wo muss ich dazu hin?
Die haben es noch nicht geschafft, die Ergebnisse
zu veröffentlichen. Achso. Das kommt demnächst auch.
Das heißt, deine App wird dann damit veröffentlicht?
Ja, die ist auf GitHub schon, aber
Wie heißt die gerade? GitHub?
VVWO.
Ja, das ist
ein schrecklich beschissenes Bospiel.
Könnte tatsächlich einfach eine Abkürzung sein.
VVO.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwas, was dir diese
GIFs, die du da reingestellt hast,
automatisch erzeugt?
Mach mal Screen Recording.
Ich mache das Screen Recording und dann mache ich es
zu einem GIF.
Mit der wunderbar tollen App von
Zintre Sorhus GIFSki,
die sehr geil ist,
um Videos zu GIFs zu machen.
Und Screen Recording of Mac OS kannst du auch mit QuickTime
Bildung machen. Stimmt, auf jeden Fall.
Nice.
Wir wollten eigentlich gerade noch ein bisschen was über
GitHub Universe erzählen, weil es irgendwie eine Kontroverse
darüber gab. Ach stimmt, das Thema haben wir noch nicht angestellt.
Ja klar. Genau. Was passiert denn da gerade?
Naja, es ist jetzt seit ein paar
Wochen schon, oder wenn nicht sogar länger, das GitHub
Verträge mit ICE, dieser
nicht Einwanderungsbehörde,
aber die sind zuständig
für...
Wofür ist ICE eigentlich zuständig?
Das ist die...
Schau es mal nach.
Organizations United States,
US Immigration and Customs Enforcement.
Ja, okay.
Immigration, Customs Enforcement.
Enforcement ist ja wahrscheinlich der spannende Teil von.
Die dafür zuständig sind,
unter anderem, um illegale Einwanderer aus dem Land
zu werfen und deswegen eine
sehr gehasste Behörde sind, weil die auch sehr
ekelhaft vorgehen. Die sich vor allem
in den letzten Monaten dadurch ausgezeichnet haben,
dass sie quasi
Konzentrationslager an den Grenzen
errichtet haben, wo sie
Leute, die illegal einwandern,
einfach nur einsperren und vor allem
Eltern von ihren Kindern trennen.
Und Kinder
monatelang ohne
Kontakt zu ihren Eltern
gefangen halten.
Das sind erstaunlich relevant, die aktuellen South Park Folgen.
Wieder mal wirklich am Zahn der Zeit.
Ich meine, South Park ist
ein fraglicher Humor
manchmal. Also es spricht nicht alle Leute an,
aber die Folgen, was sie halt absolut richtig
Ich finde es schon sehr amüsant,
aber es spricht, wie gesagt, nicht jedermann an.
Aber die Folgen,
also gerade zu dem Thema
und der ganzen China-Problematik, die aktuell
so in der Welt rumschwebt.
Southpac kann man einfach irgendwie...
Southpacstudios.de oder.com.
Die hosten ihre Folgen auch einfach selber und hier schaust du dir
einfach kostenlos an.
Die sind da sehr cool mit.
Und damit auch,
was das Imprisonment von Kindern
an der Grenze angeht, haben die wieder
in der ersten Folge der aktuellen Staffel
Perfekt, Finger drauf und richtig, richtig gut.
Zumindest ist ICE eine sehr
unbeliebte Agentur.
Irgendjemand
aus den USA
hatte mir auch neulich erzählt, ja quasi alle
US-Einrichtungen, die
eine drei Buchstabenabkürzung haben, sind schlecht.
NSA, CIA,
FBI,
ICE dann wahrscheinlich.
Ja, die heißen einfach ICE.
Ja klar, aber gibt es noch was?
Es gibt auch, ICE kann ja
im Compiler um
ICE kann ja im Compiler-Kontext
auch Internal Compiler Error
heißen. Deswegen ist die,
gibt es auch manche Issues, die zum Spaß irgendwie
Abolish ICE reinschreiben.
Zumindest, was war die Geschichte? Es gibt
ICE und GitHub
arbeitet mit ICE zusammen.
Die haben Verträge miteinander.
ICE hat vermutlich ein GitHub Enterprise am Laufen und zahlt
dafür viel Geld an GitHub
und da sind sehr viele GitHub-Mitarbeiter sehr unglücklich
mit, beziehungsweise auch sehr viele Nicht-GitHub-Mitarbeiter.
Und die Überschrift auf TechCrunch
heißt einfach momentan
GitHub faces more resignations in light of
ICE-Contract. Das sind wirklich GitHub
Employees, die kündigen und zu sagen,
mit euch mich noch nicht mehr arbeiten, solange ihr
mit ICE arbeitet. Finde ich sehr angenehm,
konsequent. Das
fordert viel Mut,
irgend sowas auch öffentlich zu sagen, beziehungsweise
da auch wirklich sein Arbeitsverhältnis
aufzuknüpfen und zu sagen, nö,
fuck it, da stehe ich, kann ich nicht mehr dahinterstehen.
Finde ich in Ordnung,
gerade da jemand, der sagen kann,
ich habe bei GitHub gearbeitet, wahrscheinlich auch kein großes Problem,
hat, einen anderen Job zu finden.
Vermutlich weniger.
Und wenn du sagst, wenn wir das machen,
ich finde
den Präzedenzfall schön, dass du,
wenn du bestimmte Sachen machst, dann einfach deine Mitarbeiter
verlierst. Finde ich cool.
Wenn jetzt eine andere Firma anfängt,
wo es natürlich,
es ist eine Agency, es ist jetzt
kein Verbrecherunternehmen oder so.
Es ist schon, eigentlich sollte man
solche Sachen über demokratische
Wege, indem man irgendwie wählt,
Deswegen ist Trump auch
da der Macht.
Anyway,
solche Auswirkungen gibt es. Es gibt auch
Bestrebungen zum Beispiel
im
TypeScript-Umfeld
gibt es ja auch Linter, zum Beispiel
TSLint.
Und TSLint wird allerdings witzigerweise
von Palantir
entwickelt.
Palantir
ist eine Firma, die
auch bloß in San Francisco
oder zumindest haben diese Leute in
das Bindeglied zwischen Tech und
Rüstungsunternehmen. Genau, die haben,
die machen halt Tech
und gar nicht mal, gar nicht mal so
uncooles Tech-Zeugs, aber halt
für Rüstungs- und für
Spionageunternehmen und so weiter und so fort.
Dafür sind die ja noch, das ist halt wirklich deren
Brot und Butter. Und deswegen ist...
Das ist halt wirklich deren Ding,
wirklich für Rüstungsunternehmen zu arbeiten
und für Spionageunternehmen zu arbeiten. Nicht nur
zusätzlich für die, sondern die existieren
hier, macht genau das.
Allerdings machen sie auch nicht unbedingt
langweiliges Zeug. Also TSLint
hat auch,
da ist ein Open-Source-Projekt,
oder zumindest ein frei benutzbares Projekt,
haben sehr viele Leute benutzt, weil es halt
für TypeScript keinen Linter gab.
ESLint wäre die Alternative, es macht
allerdings nur JavaScript.
Bis jetzt, jetzt unterstützt
ESLint auch TypeScript
und alle sagen, oh cool, dann können
plötzlich diese scheiß Palantir-Software
bei uns rausschmeißen. Wunderschön.
Und alle möglichen Projekte
migrieren gerade von TSLint nach ESLint
zurück, weil es plötzlich TypeScript
Support gibt. Finde ich witzig.
Weißt du übrigens, wo dieser
Namensreferenz
Palantir herkommt? Was das ist?
Es klingt nach
Rüstungsunternehmen direkt, finde ich, aber...
Palantir, hast du
Herr der Ringe gelesen?
Lange her.
Bei Herr der Ringe gab es in Sauromans
Tor gab es doch diese Glaskugel,
mit der er direkt mit Sauron kommuniziert hat.
Und es hat dann irgendwie natürlich auch,
weil
Frodo das Ding einmal angefasst hat,
ist er sofort irgendwie in Trance gefallen
und es hat ähnliche Auswirkungen
wie der Ring gehabt. Es ist also böse Magie.
Es ist einfach
bloß das Sauron-Telefon.
Und das Ding heißt Palantir.
Ach, kennst du dieses herrliche Bild,
wo Trump nach Saudi-Arabien ist?
Genau.
Wo er in dieser Gruppe
wenn er in diese Gruppe mit diesen Saudis steht und diesen
Palantir anfasst. Ja, ich finde es geil, dass da jemand
hier halt Saruman reingefotoshoppt hat und
es sieht halt nicht falsch aus, denn der steht halt
einfach daneben. Die hätten ihn, glaube ich,
noch spiegeln müssen, weil das Licht kommt irgendwie aus der
Fall. Ich haue das Foto mal mit in die Show Notes.
Das ist zumindest, ja. Ist natürlich
nicht bearbeitet. Aber ich muss auch sagen, es gibt
auch ein paar Contributor zu
Rust-Projekten, wo du
dann im Gitterprofil siehst, oh, der arbeitet
für Palantir und hat allerdings
sich bei diversen
coolen Rust-Crates und beim
Compiler selber mitgemacht.
Ist also so, dass wenn du coole Software machst,
kann es auch sein,
dass die für unlautere Sachen
verwenden. Ich würde mich nicht wundern.
Es ist halt das eine, ob deine Software verwendet wird,
ohne dein Zutun, oder ob du aktiv
daran beteiligt bist.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, also ich würde mich nicht wundern,
wenn Rust zum Beispiel,
wenn es nicht
bereits der Fall ist, aber spätestens in 10 Jahren
wird es halt irgendwelche
Fernlenkraketen steuern.
Das ist 100% der Fall.
Ich wette, das ist schon längst noch dabei.
Ich finde es auch schön, wenn wir mal ein paar Open-Source-Lizenzen
anfassen könnten, dass die halt
Dinge drinstehen.
Da kannst du alles noch außer Waffen
explizit vorgenommen.
Da gibt es sogar irgendwie schon Varianten von
GPL oder MIT, aber
das ist natürlich dann auch immer insofern umstritten,
als dass dann du dir die Frage
gefallen lassen musst, ist es dann wirklich
freie Software, wenn du es irgendwie
unterschiedlichen Sachen verbietest.
Ich habe auch schon überlegt, so eine
Peaceful GPL oder sowas als Lizenz.
Dann entwickelt das US-Militär
dann doch seine eigene Programmiersprache,
wo deren gesamte Arbeit
und Leistung reingeht und dann haben die eine coole
Programmiersprache, die du nicht benutzen möchtest.
Ich meine, die haben
historisch sehr viel Geld und
bauen sicherlich auch
coolen Kram, weil die sehr, sehr viel Geld
draufwerfen können, aber
haben die dafür wirklich die Mittel,
um sich von sowas komplett abzukapseln
und dann komplett von Null anzufangen?
Oder scheißen die dann auf Lizenzen?
Oder machen die das irgendwie anders?
Ich glaube, die würden eher auf Lizenzen scheißen.
Wahrscheinlich definieren sie sich dann einfach um,
das ist ja keine Waffe hier und dann passt das.
Das ist ein Verteidigungswerkzeug.
Liberation, genau.
Ja, ja. Ach, wir haben ja schöne heikle Themen
dieses Mal dabei.
Also zumindest, es war gerade GitHub Universe,
die haben auch ein paar coole Sachen veröffentlicht.
Ich würde empfehlen, die
Veröffentlichung dazu anzugucken, aber
gleichzeitig gibt es ja die Kontroverse. Das GitHub-Mitarbeiter
kündigen, weil sie dann nicht
assoziiert werden möchten
mit Eisprojekten.
Das ist krass. Finde ich gut.
Das ist auch so eine Überlegung, die du da haben musst.
Wenn du für eine
Softwarefirma arbeitest, wofür wird
diese Software eingesetzt? Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Fever hat das
glaube ich immer wieder gesagt, dass er
sich irgendwann mal den Grundsatz gesetzt hat, er möchte
nicht an Software beteiligt sein, wo Menschenleben
dranhängen. Sei das jetzt im Waffen- oder
im Verteidigungskontext oder im
medizinischen Kontext. Er möchte
daran beteiligt sein, wenn
an der Qualität seiner Software oder an der
Funktionalität seiner Software Menschenleben hängen.
Und das finde ich, also ich meine, Medizin
ist das eine, da muss es auf jeden Fall
viel geben, was da an Arbeit
reingeforscht wird. Also da sollte jemand wirklich gute Software bauen.
Ja, aber ich persönlich hätte auch
Bedenken, wenn Software, die ich schreibe,
also nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich
so sehr von der einwandfreien
Funktionalität
meiner Software überzeugt bin, dass ich
das für mich verantworten könnte, wenn da Leben dran hängt.
Klassisches Beispiel, es gibt momentan
35 Firmen, die
unabhängig voneinander Autonomous
Driving entwickeln und daran
arbeiten.
Es gibt mehrere Startups in
Deutschland, es gibt viele Startups
in den USA, die gerade genau an sowas
forschen und arbeiten und Venture-Kapital bekommen
haben und irgendeine kleine
Klitsche aus Deutschland,
hoffentlich aus Deutschland oder aus den
USA, wer weiß, wird die
Software bauen mit der nächste
Mercedes, VW, BMW
autonom fährt
und dann hoffst du,
dass das Leute bauen,
die gute Software entwickeln.
Ja.
Hofft man für alles.
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht in der Automobilbranche arbeite.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie du erzählt hast, die mal diese Werbung hatten,
von wegen hier, neue S-Klasse,
da ist drin stecken, 7 Milliarden Zeilen Code
und deswegen ist das gut.
Ja, genau, das waren Mercedes.
Die wirklich mit der Anzahl ihrer Source-Code-Zeilen
geworben haben, von wegen, das ist mehr, das ist gut.
Ich kann dir mit diesem Auto nicht mehr fahren.
Ich war es einmal in den USA, in einem Mietwagen.
Der hatte vorne so eine schöne Plakette mit dran.
Powered by Microsoft.
Wow.
Direkt cool.
Das habe ich gebraucht in dem Auto.
Ich bin persönlich froh, dass ich ein 15 Jahre altes Auto fahre,
wo nicht so viele Computer drin sind,
über die ich mir Gedanken machen muss.
Immer mehr Computer.
Immer mehr Computer?
Mehr Computer ist immer besser.
Immer mehr Computer.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gewusst habt,
wir haben das ja glaube ich schon mal angesprochen,
in unseren Show Notes checken immer alternative Titel-Vorschläge
noch mit drin.
Da haben wir jetzt schon einige, die werden wir jetzt nicht spoilern,
müsst ihr selber nachgucken.
Zum Thema, mehr Computer sind immer besser.
Da viele Leute haben ja
Computer bei sich daheim in Form von
Sprachassistenten rumstehen.
Da sind mehr auch immer besser?
Da sind mehr logischerweise wie
überall anders auch besser, weil mehr Computer
immer besser sind. Und da gab es
letztens ein paar Leute, ein paar Forscher, die haben
einen sehr coolen Angriff darauf gefahren.
Und zwar haben sie das Projekt
Light Commands genannt und haben mit einem
Laser auf Mikrofone
geleuchtet und haben gemerkt, dass du mit
Licht auf ein Mikrofon Spannung
induzieren kannst und somit das Mikrofon
überzeugst, etwas gehört zu haben.
Ach du Scheiße. Und so kannst du,
das haben sie dann demonstriert im Angriff, auf
100 Meter Entfernung mit einem Laser,
also nicht quasi mit der Taschenlampe auf dem Mikro leuchtet,
aber mit einem Laser auf 100 Meter Entfernung
Google Home oder Alexa leuchten und
auf das Mikro halt zeigen
und ins Licht
rein moduliert,
quasi den Befehl, also wahrscheinlich
nicht genauso wie der Sprachbefehl, aber
auf irgendeine Art und Weise an ihm rein
moduliert und konnte es dann eben
dementsprechend Befehle auf dem Gerät
auslösen. Und das Ganze haben sie dann sogar so weit
getrieben, dass sie von einem anderen Gebäude durchs
Fenster in diesem Raum
hinein auf dem Alexa Befehle
ausgeführt haben. Super
clever.
faszinierend.
Das ist ein bisschen angelehnt an diese
optischen Mikrofone, die sie entwickelt haben.
Es gibt Techniken,
mit denen du, wenn du ein
einigermaßen hochqualitatives
Video von einem Raum hast,
dann kannst du hören, was da
passiert ist, indem du irgendwie auf Reflexion, Vibration
von irgendwelchen Sachen
hast.
Es ist nicht komplett, geht nicht bei jedem Video.
Du brauchst eine ziemlich hohe Frequenz
und dann solltest du am besten sowas wie eine
Chips-Tüte-Filmen oder sowas, was irgendwie auch
mitschwingt. Aber ich weiß nicht, dass sowas
überhaupt möglich ist.
Was mir sofort als Frage eingefallen ist,
als du das erwähnt hast, es gibt
AIs, die
Gesichter erkennen. Es gibt aber auch
Algorithmen oder AIs,
die Sachen erzeugen, die nicht
wie Gesichter aussehen und als Gesichter erkannt werden.
Und es gibt auch
AIs, die Fotos von deinem Gesicht
so verändern, dass sie für dich
immer noch wie ein Gesicht aussehen, aber von einer AI nicht mehr
erkannt werden.
Hast du ja mal einen coolen Kongress-Talk zu von wegen, wie man sich schminken muss, um von der Gesichtserkennung sofern nicht erkannt zu werden?
Mir stellt sich jetzt erstens die Frage,
muss ich, wenn ich, was weiß ich,
dein Apple AirPod
aus dem Fenster,
durchs Fenster mit einem Laser angreife,
muss ich wirklich Sprache da rein modulieren
oder kann ich irgendein Signal rein,
was zufällig, was, nee,
was nicht ein akustisches Signal wäre,
sondern was,
oder zumindest ein Sprachsignal wäre,
aber irgendeine andere Geräuschsequenz,
die von der Spracherkennung
als Befehl erkannt werden würde.
Genau, das gab es auch schon als Angriff
im Ultraschallbereich.
Dass diese Geräte alle im Ultraschallbereich
quasi auch ihre Hotwood Detection
angreifen lassen und du halt einfach
was reinschmeißt, was für das Gerät klingt
wie Alexa so und so.
Hast du hier irgendwas zuhören?
Warte mal, ich habe ja extra eine Fernbedienung, mit der ich das
wieder ausmache.
Ich wusste nicht, dass du hier sowas betreibst.
Stimmt, wir hatten sogar mal
einer Folge darüber gesprochen. Also es ist ewig her.
Ja, ich habe eine in der Küche und eine im
Bad, aber ich habe auch
aber ich habe auch
meine Wohnung mit dieser schönen
mit diesen schönen Funksteckdosen
ausgestattet, mit denen ich hier in meinem
Wohnzimmer diverse Lichter an und aus
machen kann. Und
die Alexen haben ja einen eigenen Kanal.
Deshalb, wenn ich
diesen Knopf drücke, dann sind beide
gleichzeitig tot. Alexa, bestelle
10 Kilo Hundefutter. Alexa, Bestellung
bestätigen.
Zu spät, sie hört nicht mehr zu.
Und ich habe auch das Einkaufen, also ganz ehrlich,
ich habe auch das Einkaufen abgestellt.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob...
Warum will man sowas überhaupt?
Amazon will, dass du das willst.
Natürlich, okay, logisch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich mir nochmal eine kaufen würde.
Allgemein,
die,
das Feature, was ich haben wollte,
war Multiroom Audio.
Und, dass
ich einfach eine Spotify
habe, wo ich sagen kann, spiele
Spotify auf diesem, in jedem Gerät.
Für was anderes benutze ich das Ding nicht mehr.
Witzigerweise kommst du allerdings nicht mehr
umhin, so ein Ding
zu besitzen irgendwo, weil
mittlerweile jeder bessere Lautsprecher und
jedes bessere Radio sowas integriert hat.
Das heißt sogar in Kopfhörer.
Du kaufst so Bose-Kopfhörer.
Super Ekelhaft. So was will ich da nicht noch
am Kopf klemmen haben. Meine Eltern haben sich
halt so eine Bose-Soundbar geholt.
Da ist auch Amazon Echo
drauf.
Das hat den witzigen Effekt, das Ding ist
auch noch per HDMI
an den Fernseher angeschlossen. Das heißt,
das Audiosignal
geht vom Fernseher über HDMI an diese Soundbar
und du kannst
die Alexa
darauf einrichten. Das wollten die auch haben.
Und es hat
den witzigen Effekt, dass du dann im Wohnzimmer einfach sagen kannst,
spiel mal diese Musik. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Und das kommt dann aus dieser Soundbar raus.
Das ist in Ordnung. Du kannst aber auch sagen, mach den Fernseher an.
Dann geht der Fernseher an, weil du über HDMI ein Signal
rückwärts schicken kannst.
Genau.
Wir haben auf Arbeit immer das Problem,
dass wir debuggern ja so
Raum-Telefonanlagen.
Wie nennt man das überhaupt?
Conference-Systeme.
Wir debuggern ja solche
Conference-Systeme von einem Hersteller,
der mit uns partnert.
Und die sind halt auch
per HDMI an einen Fernseher angeschlossen,
der bei uns im Raum hängt.
Und wir müssen das HDMI-Kabel
regelmäßig rausziehen, weil sonst
diese Konferenzboxen
den Fernseher einfach immer wieder anmachen.
Geht manchmal einfach so an und dann ist er halt ein.
Fertig.
Über Ultraschall gibt es da tatsächlich schon einen Angriff,
dass du komplett im Ultraschallbereich
nicht Sprache, sondern
andere Audiosignale senden kannst
und die von den Geräten halt auf der Grund der Tatsache,
dass die halt nicht wie ein Mensch Sprache verstehen,
sondern aufgrund von irgendwelchen Machine Learning Modellen
da halt genauso in dieselben
Signale reingefährst.
Mir war aber, als hätte ich mal
dem widersprechende Aussagen gehört,
ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht, bei welchem dieser
fünf Assistenten es war, aber dass
explizit darauf geachtet wird, dass
der Befehl in dem Frequenzbereich
von menschlicher Sprache ist.
Vielleicht war das schon der fixte Befehl.
Oder damit ein bestimmtes,
oder vielleicht achten sie auch einfach drauf, ob ein bestimmtes
Frequenzband mit dabei ist oder nicht
mit dabei ist. Und es gibt auch welche
Mechanismen, die dafür sorgen,
dass sie nicht ihre eigene Stimme erkennen.
Wenn zwei von den Dingern nebeneinander stehen.
Scheint aber nicht so ganz zu funktionieren.
ich habe neulich mal zum Spaß,
stand ich hier und wollte was kochen,
wollte ich Pfannkuchen machen und habe mir gedacht,
eigentlich könnte ich mal nochmal, manchmal
macht man so zum Spaß, Alexa sagt mir, wie mache ich Pfannkuchen?
Und dann ging es so,
es ging halt immer so ein Programm los,
da denkst du, bitte schneller.
Jetzt kannst du halt nicht bei den Dingern einstellen,
dass die schneller sprechen. Wenn du es mittlerweile von Podcasts
oder sogar was gewohnt bist, dann ist dir das alles zu langsam.
Und dann
ging es so, ja,
möchtest du das jetzt kochen?
Und die gesagt, ja, gut, du brauchst
diese Zutaten, diese Zutaten, diese Zutaten,
und diese Zutaten. Wenn du bereit bist,
fortzufahren, dann sage einfach Alexa.
Dann hatte sie sich selbst verstanden.
Dann kam kein Input.
Das ist ja armselig.
Und dann habe ich drei Sekunden gewartet,
dann hat das Ding festgestellt, du sagst keiner mehr was.
Komisch. Dann hat es diesen Satz
mal von vorne angefangen. Wenn du bereit bist,
weiterzukommen, dann sag bitte einfach Alexa.
Das kann jetzt nicht dein Ernst sein.
Das ging fünfmal im Kreis. Ich hatte schon
mein Handy in der Hand und wollte das filmen.
In dem Moment hat er dann aber gerade aufgehört und ist fertig gewesen.
Oh, das ist ja
Das war richtig dumm.
Ja, aber Sprachausgabe hat ja
in klassischer Weise, also so wie ich es
aus Microsoft-ZAM-Zeiten sogar noch kenne,
immer diesen Schiegel-Regel für Geschwindigkeit gehabt.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich,
das ist ja kein Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, wie moderne Sprachausgabe funktioniert, die ist ja nicht mehr
so, also
das sind ja auch irgendwie, wo teilweise,
wenn wir Einstiegsthema sind,
teilweise sogar Mundformen simuliert
werden, um
vor allem die Laute, die aufeinander folgen,
passend klingen zu lassen, menschlich erkennen zu lassen.
Das ist ja recht hochkarätiges Zeug.
Genau. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es Veritasium war oder sowas.
Wo es
dieses Lautalphabet
Phonetisches
Das ist eine neue Kategorie
Podcast, Veritasium Video der Woche.
Ja. Das letzte war übrigens
super spannend, was du
gezeigt hast mit diesem Tennis-Wacket-Effekt.
Achso, dass das Ding sich
in der Luft komisch dreht? Ja.
Die Erklärung fand ich auch sehr einleuchtend.
Es war nicht
Veritasium, es war Tom Scott,
der Typ mit dem roten T-Shirt.
Die Zusammenfassung zumindest,
ich will es nicht unbedingt spoilern, schaut es euch auf jeden Fall an,
aber es gibt halt dieses Alphabet, das ist danach sortiert,
wo es im Mund entsteht und ob es ein
Plosiv oder irgendwie
ein Vokal ist.
Das hast du mir die Show-Notes betreiben.
Das packe ich mal in die Show-Notes.
Die haben halt einfach auch auf dem,
die haben unterschiedliche Bereiche
in dieser Tabelle markiert,
die entweder noch von keiner
Sprache benutzt werden, aber aussprechbar
sind.
Okay. Oder
die nicht von Menschen aussprechbar sind.
Weil du kannst zum Beispiel... Aber in diversen
Sprachen schon benutzt werden. Du kannst zum Beispiel
ein Plosiv
nicht hinten im Hals machen oder sowas.
Oder irgendeine Sachen. Ich kriege es
nicht mehr zusammen, aber schaut euch dieses Video mal an.
Ich habe es gerade in die Short-Nutz geschmissen. Sehr gut.
Ja,
wir haben bereits eine
beachtliche Länge, die ich jetzt nicht
erwähne, erreicht.
wollen wir uns auf
Pics stürzen und damit
diesen Podcast
gekonnt abrunden. Gerne.
Ich sehe von dir noch gar keine Pics im Pad,
deswegen fange ich mal mit meinen an.
Oh ja. Und zwar ist das
das Erste, ist leider kein wirklich sinnvolles
GitHub-Repo. Das heißt Tamagotchi
Temp. Da ist auch wirklich bloß im Repo
selber ein kompiliertes Projekt mit drin.
Das ist eine macOS-App.
Aber ich fand das so witzig. Das ist ein Tamagotchi,
der auf deiner Touch Bar läuft.
Das ist ein kleines Kätzchen, was mit ihm herläuft.
kannst du füttern, kannst du streicheln, schlecht zeigen.
Blüderweise ist das,
weil so wie die Touchpoint implementiert ist,
das kann man auch anders machen, glaube ich, aber
in der Version, die ich mir vorgestern installiert habe,
oder gestern,
siehst du das Tamagotchi nicht,
wenn das App-Fenster nicht aktiv ist,
das leere App-Fenster,
und dann arbeitest du kurz mal weiter,
und dann schweckst du wieder rüber, und dann ist das Tamagotchi am Sterben.
Was?
Aber das finde ich witzig.
Weil es einfach kaputt ist, oder wie?
Du hast nicht gesehen, wie es im Hintergrund hungert,
Das ist ja doof
Aber ich finde, Tamagotchis
können gerne immer alle zwei Jahre so ein Comeback haben
Vor allem
auf unterschiedlichen Plattformen
This One's Doom
muss auch 20 Tamagotchis haben
Apropos This One's Doom
Ich kann gerade noch einen Zweitpick mit reinschieben
Bitte, bitte, bitte
Ich bin ja
im Matrix-Ecosystem recht aktiv
unterwegs und lese damit Freude auch immer
die This Week in Matrix Blogposts
Es gibt ein This Week in Matrix.
Es gibt ein This Week in Matrix, wo immer sehr tolle Highlights auch mit drinstehen.
Und da war letztens einer drin, der hat ein Matrix-Client-SDK
und die Woche drauf ein Matrix-Client geschrieben für den Nintendo 3DS.
Cool.
What the fuck?
Aber okay, warum nicht? Ich meine, kann es auch geben.
Und ein Kumpel von mir, Ian, hört uns glaube ich nicht, aber wenn doch, hi Ian,
meinte, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es bei ihm auf Arbeit war oder nicht,
oder woanders, ob ihr es nur vom Hörensagen kennt,
ich glaube aber, das ist bei ihm auf Arbeit,
dass irgendwie Bug-Reports reinkommen, die machen Web-Software
oder so, glaube ich. Korrigiere mich
bitte, Ian, von irgendwelchen
3DS-Nutzern, die da
hier mal einen Bug hatten auf dem
3DS-Browser.
Und dann denkst du, wow, ich meine,
ihr habt nicht mal ein Tausendstel Prozent
oder nicht mal ein Promille, was ihr hier an
Nutzer habt. Aber krass, dass es da
sich Leute gibt. Ich hatte am Wochenende
eine sehr schöne Debugging-Experience.
Mein Vater meint, ah, das geht nicht, ich habe das
stundenlang probiert oder sowas und dann
sollte ich ihm helfen und zwar
Smart TVs.
Smart TVs, schönes Thema.
Schrecklich, schrecklich.
Macht Spaß, ich habe keinen und ich kann euch
nur davon abraten. Ich habe leider einen,
aber das vergeblich nicht, weil
ich nicht die Vermittlung von dem
Ding nutze, der hängt nicht am Netzwerk, der macht
nichts. Anyway, mein Vater wollte gerne
mit seinem Kumpel in sein Büro,
wo sie sich sonntags immer treffen
und irgendwie Fußball gucken wollte,
mit seinem Kumpel Fußball gucken.
Und zwar
auf dem Smart TV, den er
dort unten hat. Und zwar
Fußball, was er über Sky
gucken kann. Er hat sich so ein Sky-Ticket gekauft
und wollte
das gerne gucken. Und er hat gesagt, das geht da einfach irgendwie nicht.
Ich habe mich da eingeloggt und dann passiert nichts.
Hä? Okay. Dann habe ich überlegt,
du hast dich hier oben auf dem eingeloggt.
Vielleicht kannst du dir so und so häufig eingeloggt sein.
Oder sowas. Also der erste Intuition.
Ich habe mich
in sein Büro gestellt und gesagt, zeig mal.
und dann gesagt, naja, also ich gehe hier auf Apps
und dann gehe ich auf Webbrowser und dann gehe ich
auf SkyTicket, weil die gesagt haben, du kannst
das ja auch online im Browser gucken
da habe ich gedacht, okay, fuck
da habe ich diesen Browser genommen, da habe ich erstmal
den Fernseher, Maus und Tastatur angeschlossen, damit ich
da überhaupt eine Adresse eingeben kann
und dann bin ich auf ifconfig.io gegangen
damit ich irgendeine Seite habe, die mit den UserAgentString
von diesem Ding angewendet und das war
in Opera9 oder so
aber das läuft doch wahrscheinlich nicht auf dem SmartTV
Browser, das war doch deren Intention
Das Problem zum Schluss war,
mein Vater wollte es im Webbrowser auf dem
Smart TV ausführen und
der ist natürlich, wir bringen diese
DRM-Features nicht mit und einige Sachen.
Und alles andere.
Und vieles andere auch, es ist minimaler Nachrichtenlese.
Wahrscheinlich reicht es dafür mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Ein Browser auf dem Fernseher.
Ja, prinzipiell ist es ganz cool.
Es sollte überall laufen, ein Browser, aber was macht man damit?
Wie nutzt man sowas denn?
Ein Statusmonitor für irgendwas.
Ja, klar, auf jeden Fall.
Der zeigt dir auch einfach die letzten Seiten, die du besucht hast,
und wenn du einen Grafana-Sport
aufmachen willst, brauchst du nicht...
Kann ja bestimmt gut rendern, die
JavaScript-lastigen Grafen.
Aber hey, ich meine, die Idee finde ich gut.
Da ist mehr Leistung drin als in einem
Raspberry Pi, es wird wohl falsch.
Anyway,
Quintessenz war,
geht nicht in den Browser und
für den Fernseher, was in dem Fall
in Philips war, gibt es natürlich
von Sky auch keine App.
Weil da irgendein System...
Das heißt, du brauchst irgendwie so einen Fire TV Stick
oder einen Apple TV oder irgendwas.
Für einen Fire TV Stick gibt es die App auch nicht,
weil Sky nur für begrenzt viele,
für Comcast und für andere Sachen das macht.
Und jetzt muss es sich so einen komischen
Sky Stick holen.
Einen eigenen Sky Stick auch.
Einen eigenen Sky Stick.
Was nicht alles gibt.
Kurz mit einem Apple TV geliebäugelt,
aber das kostet halt irgendwie sechsmal so viel
wie, oder achtmal so viel wie ein Sky Stick.
Ja.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Aber cool, es gibt This Week in Matrix.
kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ist sehr spannend.
Sehr nice. Ich habe gerade mal was rausgesucht,
was ich neulich wieder...
Was wollte ich denn empfehlen?
Ja stimmt, ich habe ja gar nicht so viel diese Woche.
Aber die Woche war auch voll mit...
Ich war auf dem Rust-Fest.
Deswegen ist meine Empfehlung, schaut euch mal
den Rust-Analyzer an, anstatt
das bereits existierende RLS.
Das RLS
Plugin? Nee. Anstatt der
RLS-Extension, die es bereits gibt, kann man
leider momentan nicht einfach über diesen Plugin,
diese Plugin-Sitebar installieren in
VS Code, sondern man geht auf
diese Rust-Up-Components, die du hinzufügen kannst?
Genau. Geil, okay. Das finde ich auch
sehr angenehm, wie gut das alles läuft.
Das geht aber nicht über Rust-Up-Component.
Nee, was ich meine, du kannst es nicht einfach aus
VS Code installieren, indem du es da als Plugin suchst.
Ach so, okay. Sondern du musst das Repo
klonen und dann aus dem Repo das bauen.
Und dann installiert es sich aber witzigerweise selber, indem es
an das Cargo noch einen
Jahrenbefehl
ausführt und dann den JavaScript-Code,
den es dafür braucht, um die Extension zu bauen, baut
und das dann tatsächlich für dich auch
automatisch in dein VS Code installiert.
Krass. Das ist ziemlich nice.
Was nicht so gut funktioniert mit VS
Codium, da wollte ich ja noch ein bisschen
was nachträglich zu erzählen, nachdem wir das das letzte Mal
erwähnt haben. Ich habe mir VS Codium installiert
und es ist ziemlich cool.
Mal kurz zurück, das war quasi Chromium-Aquivalent
zu, äh, das ist Chromium zu Chromus,
VS Codium zu VS Code. Da muss ich auch noch einiges korrigieren,
was ich darüber gesagt habe. Es ist nicht
weniger
Telemetry oder freier als
VS Code. Es ist
VS Code und für einen
Außenstehenden
ist es komplett identisch, bis auf, dass das Icon
anders ist.
Die Sache
mit VS Code ist,
der Source-Code ist
Open Source.
Aha.
Die Binary ist nicht.
Das heißt, wenn du dir VS Code runterlädst.
Ach so, das ist quasi gebaut aus den VS Code-Sources.
Es ist gepackaged und
distributed von Microsoft
und Microsoft
es bestehen andere Regeln
drauf, deswegen gibt es
VS Codeium einfach, ein
Set von Skripten, was dir
regelmäßig aus dem VS Code
baut
und dann dir
ein alternatives Installationsmedium
zur Verfügung stellt.
Die Namensgebung macht es echt schwer,
was ein bisschen witzig ist,
ich habe es auf Mac installiert, da hat es
direkt VS Code ersetzt.
Das heißt, es ersetzt auch
diese...
Es liegt beides nebeneinander, aber
der Kommandozeilenbefehl
Code hat dann auf VS Code verwiesen.
Was ein bisschen unangenehm in dem Moment war,
war, dass wir nicht
denselbe Settings-Verzeichnis wie VS Code verwenden.
Das heißt, ich musste mir dann
diverse Add-ons nochmal neu installieren
oder irgendwie rüberziehen.
Gerade das Settings-Dier sollte man bei sowas idealerweise...
Weißt du, ob sie es wollen?
Es hat einfach einen anderen Ordner und das ist halt extra Arbeit
zu gucken, gibt es das andere schon, dann ziehe ich das jetzt mal rüber.
Dann machen sie einfach nicht.
Ich hätte gedacht, der liegt einfach auf das Verzeichnis, aber das denkt ja wahrscheinlich
dann wirklich auf macOS in der Bundle-IT fest, wo das
an einem Application Support liegt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es auf macOS
ist, auf Linux war es einfach
in meinem Home Directory ein anderes.folder.
Was dann auch den
Effekt hatte, dass als ich mir
Rust Analyzer installieren wollte, ging es halt
nicht, weil Rust Analyzer halt erstmal
per default für VS Code direkt
vorkonfiguriert ist und da
gab es dann ein GitHub-Ishore, wo beschrieben wurde, ja, dann
musst du bitte dieses Skript mit diesem Parameter ausfüllen,
damit das nicht dorthin, sondern dorthin
installiert. So, fertig. Aber
VS Codeium kann man durchaus benutzen. Die sind auch
komplett kompatibel.
Es ist nicht weniger
Telemetry drin. Der Code ist derselbe.
Aber man kann ja auch bei
VS Code diesen Telemetry-Haken in den
Settings einfach ausmachen.
Und hoffen, dass das dann heißt.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine,
Telemetry ist jetzt
ist ja jetzt kein
personalisiertes Tracking,
die betreiben
Es kann da aber schon sehr mit reinfallen.
Es kann da durchaus
abgeleitet werden, aber in den meisten
Fällen, würde ich den Softwareherstellern
unterstellen,
dass es für den Betrieb ihre eigene Infrastruktur
und die Vorderentwicklung der Software
tatsächlich nur Daten sammeln und nicht versuchen
so ein Zellmitteln.
Wo klickt der
Benutzer hin und was macht er meistens, damit ich
immer ein bisschen Werbung schalten kann oder sowas.
Das mache ich sehr bloß mit den Endkunden dann
auf Windows und nicht mit den Entwicklern
für various code.
Möchte ich mal hoffen.
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist,
aber unser
Client schickt halt auch
Telemetry raus, damit wir nachvollziehen können,
wann mal was schiefgegangen ist
in der Session. Crashlogs willst du auf jeden Fall sammeln.
Crashlogs willst du haben.
Prinzipiell ist ja der
DSGVO-kompatible Ansatz, sammel so
wenig wie möglich und das, was du sammelst,
sammelst du anonym, damit du die Daten gar nicht hast,
damit du was von denen kannst.
Ist ja immer ein guter Grundgedanke,
den viele Leute nicht verstehen.
Ich habe letztens mal auf meiner Fritzbox
Empfehlungen im
Swiftie-E-Slack eine stark große
Blocklist einfach mal reingeschmissen.
Wie macht man das?
Das habe ich auch nicht gewusst, dass das geht. Du kannst direkt in den
Filtereinstellungen der Fritzbox hier eine Liste
an Domains angeben. Da gab es Leute, die maintainen
so eine Blocklist. Leider kannst du nicht einfach die URL
davon angeben, sondern du musst die tatsächlich selber reinpasten
ins Format der Fritzbox. Und da gibt es glaube ich auch
Sprich, die müssen alle da raus.
Und dann musst du halt noch manuell ein paar Sachen kicken,
die du zulassen möchtest. Aber es war erstaunlich,
wie viele Dinge erstmal nicht gehen, beziehungsweise welche Webseiten
alle so, oh mein Gott, ich weiß nicht mehr,
wie ich an Mixpanel.com
meine ganzen Analytics-Daten hier schicken soll.
Also es ist quasi sowas wie
Piehole. Es ist Piehole auf Ritzbock-Basis.
Nice, ich wollte mir neulich mal
einen meiner Raspies als Piehole
einrichten, aber wenn ich das gar nicht machen muss, kannst du ja mal
einen Link zu diesen Sachen in die
Shownotes pasten.
Das hat mich jetzt auch sehr...
Ich habe mir auch ein PyHole aufsetzen wollen,
beziehungsweise ich wollte PyHole eigentlich als Docker-Container
auf meinem Synology NAS einfach starten.
Aber mein Networking-Setup mit dem Synology NAS
hat es mir sehr schwer gemacht,
das als DNS-Server zu nutzen,
weswegen ich das erstmal aufgeschoben habe.
Dann wollte ich auch
den UASB nochmal dafür nutzen,
aber bin ich noch nicht dazu gekommen.
PyHole hat zum einen eine schöne Web-UI noch,
die echt schick ist, wo er dir sagt,
was er alles blockt und wie viel er so geblockt hat.
Und was auch sehr praktisch ist,
du kannst PyHole kurzfristig angenehm disablen,
sogar über einen schicken API-Call einfach im Lokalnetz.
Da könntest du dir einen großen roten Button hier hinlegen
und draufhauen und ins Pyro 5 Minuten aus,
wenn du mal kurz was brauchst.
Nicht schlecht.
Also wenn du wirklich mal kurz hier ekelhaftes Internet wieder haben möchtest.
Aber ansonsten hat Pyro halt den anderen Nachteil,
ich möchte nicht von außerhalb
meinen Traffic eigentlich durch mein
Heimnetzwerk tunneln, weil mein Heimnetzwerk
gefühlt fragiler ist als
andere Sachen und ich möchte vor allem nicht auf Arbeit
durch sein Netzwerk gehen und auf Arbeit kriege ich kein Pyro
leider hin. Deswegen bin ich halt darauf angewiesen,
auch zusätzlich noch irgendwie im Browser Blocker zu nutzen.
Pyhole ist vornehmlich
für Adblocking gedacht.
Es ist Adblocking
beziehungsweise das, was du halt über DNS-Blocking
halt machen kannst.
Ich habe mal den mutigen
Versuch gestartet und habe
diverse Tracker-Blocker in meinem
Firefox deaktiviert
und verlasse mich
seitdem, dass in Firefox unterstützt
wird, eigentlich fast ausschließlich
auf die in Firefox
mittlerweile eingebaute
Tracker-Blocking-Funktionalität.
Okay. Also ich habe jetzt nur noch
Was mit Werbung und so Scheiß?
Werbung ist noch da, dafür habe ich Ublock Origin.
Achso, okay. Aber
ich habe das mal alles ausgemacht, weil
mir der Firefox-Blocker,
Tracker-Blocker, der seit
69, 70 in Firefox drin ist,
gesagt,
die Seite hat überhaupt keine
Datus-basierte Versionen wieder einführen,
dass man sagen kann, Firefox 2019
5. Das wäre eigentlich bei Firefox fast mal
in der Zeit, also gerade dadurch, dass sie jetzt von einem
sechswöchigen auf eine, von einer
sechswöchigen auf eine vierwöchige
Kadenz wechseln.
Das ist auch mal für, ich glaube Marco
Arment, der Overcast-Entwickler
hat es mal erzählt im Podcast, seitdem mache
ich das für alle Apps, die ich maintaine
auch mit. Endnutzer
brauchen in executable Produkten,
also in der App zum Beispiel, brauchst
du keine Semantic-Versioning.
Und das Maintainen ist halt auch immer so eine
Sache, weil was ist denn ein Major-Version-Upgrade
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Diskussionen. Da würde ich gerne mal
einen Kollegen von mir, der unsere Web-App
maintained einladen. Die haben da nämlich eine
interessante Meinung.
Deswegen bin ich halt auch umgestiegen auf das, was Marco Amand
da mal erzählt hat. Von wegen, Apps von mir
werden jetzt gepublished mit der Versionsnummer
2019 Punkt. Und dahinter kommt
die wievielte Version
dieses Jahr schon ist. Deswegen die erste
Version dieses Jahr 2021. Die zweite
ist nicht der Monat dahinter, sondern der
Account, der dann 2020 wieder gesettet wird.
So versionieren wir in unserer Firma
unsere zentrale Plattform-Library
oder die Library...
Ich tue, das machen wir auch, ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Ha, witzig.
Also zumindest
das ganz große
Systemding, was eigentlich
nach außen, also was kaum noch eine
Abhängigkeit von irgendwas anderem ist, weil
alles, was davon abhängt, einfach mit reingewandert ist.
Da gibt es einfach bloß, das ist
quasi keine...
Semware ist ja
eine Versionsbeschreibung, die dann
das Äußere deiner API
beschreibt. Bei vielen Sachen
brauchst du das nicht. Ich möchte fest behaupten,
beim Linux-Körnel brauchst du das nicht.
Bei Ubuntu brauchst du das nicht. Dementsprechend gibt es da solche
Jahres-Releases. Das sagt einfach, wann ist es rausgekommen.
Bei Ubuntu finde ich das auch super schick. Das ist super.
Wir haben aber auch weiteren
Libraries, die wir semantically versionieren
und zwar, weil andere Leute die benutzen.
Dafür ist es ja da.
Genau, dafür ist es da. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel
auch unsere Web-App.
Hat auch eine Semantic-Version.
Version?
Eine semantische Versionsnummer.
Und ich habe dann nochmal mit einem der Maintainer
von unserer App, warum macht ihr das eigentlich?
Der hat gemeint,
naja, deine UI ist auch
eine API-Garantie.
Ja, ist sehr schwammig.
Und die machen jedes Mal, wenn sich
absolut nichts ändert oder wenn Sachen hinzukommen,
machen sie halt Miner- und Fix-Version.
Und wenn jetzt sich was ändert,
was wirklich für den Nutzer
sichtbar ist, dass irgendwie was von links
nach rechts wandert oder dass irgendwie was
unbenannt wird, dann
ist es bei denen auch ein Major-Version-Update.
Das ist was, was unsere Kunden nie sehen.
Das kommt auch noch zu, wie viele Kunden
harten auf so einen Versionssprung.
Die Nummer, die Version siehst du nicht als Kunde.
Bei viel Software hast du es ja.
Der Unterschied zwischen Minor und Major
kann ich schon verstehen in dem Kontext.
Das kann man begründen.
Aber die Fix bzw. Patch Version, die ist halt wirklich nutzlos dann.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, wie viel
attributierst du der Versionsnummer wirklich?
Also viele Leute werben ja hier,
das ist jetzt die App 2.0, das hier ist jetzt
Industrie 4.0.
Das sagt halt mehr aus für, es hat sich,
Also ich meine, Industrie 4.0-Kontakt ist
ein bisschen fragwürdig, aber
das sagt mehr aus für, wir haben grundlegend Dinge
geändert. Also sie machen das glaube ich so,
dass sie wirklich die
Major-Version nur hochziehen, wenn sich massiv
was ändert und ansonsten nur die Miner-Version
hochziehen und die Patch-Version glaube ich
fast nie. Zumindest momentan
ist die Version unserer Web-App
17.94.0.
94, krass.
Genau, und da kommt halt,
und das ist halt, das zählen sie einfach
die Iteration des Releases
könnte auch eine Bildnummer sein, quasi.
Theoretisch.
Jedes Mal, wenn irgendwas Neues auf
Beta released wird, dann ist das eine neue
Nummer.
Einfach nur noch Jahreszeitpunkt Bildnummer, warum nicht?
Genau.
Das finde ich bei Apps ein interessantes Konzept,
weil was ist eine Versionsnummer von Firefox?
Bei Firefox kann es ja auch
UI-Apps machen.
Wenn sie auf eine monatliche Kadenz gehen, können sie wirklich sagen,
das ist Version 1911
und danach kommt 1912, das ist einfach
der Monat, in dem das rauskam.
Die Unterscheidung zwischen der App und der Webseite
ist ja jetzt auch infällig.
Kannst du genauso festmachen, ist es für den Nutzer
wirklich anders oder nicht?
Ja, genau.
Es ist ja fragwürdig, inwiefern das
der Nutzer überhaupt tangiert. Und gerade bei
der Anzahl an Firefox oder an Browser-Releases
generell, finde ich es angenehmer, wenn du
dann wirklich referenzieren kannst, wann kam das raus
und ist das was Aktuelles.
Bei Browsern ist es tatsächlich
auch eher für Entwickler, die mit dem Browser arbeiten,
interessant. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich
Firefox-Releases auch nicht installiert habe.
Keine Ahnung, das aktuelle vermutlich.
Als Webentwickler möchtest du wissen, gerade
wir, wo sich der Standard, mit dem
wir arbeiten, immer noch sehr
in Bewegung befindet, möchten wir wissen, wie
viele Versionen von Chrome
77, 78,
benutzen unsere Kunden gerade.
Damit wir sagen können, okay, dieses Feature können wir
immer noch nicht benutzen,
weil eine signifikante Anzahl unserer Kunden
noch nicht die aktuelle Chrome-Version hat.
Möglicherweise aktualisiert sich Chrome
selber.
Du kannst sagen, wie bleibt man als Kunde auf einer ewig alten
Chrome-Werse, wenn das Ding selbst abdaten ist?
Du kannst in einem Enterprise-Kontext sein, wo dein Administrator
auf deinem dir voreingestellten Windows
oder so eingestellt hat,
dass bestimmte Sachen nicht geupdatet werden.
Und dann kann das passieren, das ist bei Chrome
relativ selten, aber es gibt zum Beispiel bei Firefox
gibt es ja diese ESL-Variante.
Ja, nee, das heißt nicht Extended Shelf Life,
das heißt... Extended Shelf Life?
Das war bei mir nicht.
Oh, da gibt es diesen schönen
Subway, Aged Like Milk.
für Dinge, die nicht gut gealtert sind.
Ich finde,
der Ausbruch Age-Light-Milk einfach nur schön,
das müssen wir mal mehr in passenden
Kontexten anbringen.
Das muss ich jetzt mal raussuchen.
Anyway, also ich habe, glaube ich,
außer Rust-Credits keine
großen Empfehlungen. Ich habe noch einen Pick,
bevor wir zum Ende kommen,
wenn du klingst, als ob du...
Mir fällt sonst nicht viel ein,
Aber bitte, bitte.
Einfach, was dir wahrscheinlich mit gefallen könnte, finde ich.
Das ist von Deezer,
die auch noch diese Musikplattform haben, die keiner nutzt.
Ich kenne einen,
der die benutzt. Tatsächlich?
Krass. Okay. Die haben ein
Python-Package rausgebracht, das heißt Splitter.
Okay.
Splitter, bloß mit Doppel-E, weil sie von Deezer
kommt.
Und das ist ein auf TensorFlow aufbauendes Paket,
was durch krasse
pre-trained Models hier deine Musik
in verschiedene Sources
separiert. Ob das jetzt der Vocal Track ist, ob das
diverse andere Tracks sind,
hier nur die Drums, Bass, Piano
und noch andere Dinge.
Bis zu, glaube ich, fünf Stems, sagen sie hier,
die Dinge auseinanderzerren. Das ist nice.
Und es klingt fancy,
natürlich überhaupt keinen Anwendungsfall,
ich persönlich dafür, aber ich fand, das sah einfach super
cool aus. Du kannst ja aus allem, was auf
Deezer läuft, das könnte man sich
jetzt vorstellen, das baust du in der App,
dann machst du die App zu einem
verifizierten Deezer oder Spotify
oder was ist das?
Und dann kannst du eine Karaoke-App draus machen.
Und dann kannst du noch mit Machine Learning
machen, dass es dir
die Lyrics rausliest
und dann kannst du die unten drunter einblenden.
Das geht eigentlich ziemlich gut. Also ich glaube,
Karaoke lässt sich momentan komplett automatisch erzeugen
mit Machine Learning.
Das wäre eigentlich wirklich mal so ein... Ich meine, wir haben ja
diesen Ultrastar-Freundeskreis,
wo wir...
Was automatisch diese Ultrastar
generiert.
Ich meine, es sei jetzt mal
hergestellt, wo das herkommt, aber wenn
da jetzt nur einen YouTube-Link reinkippst oder so,
dann hast du Video, du hast Audio, du hast dann
aufgrund von dieser Software
die Vocals raus, du kannst auch
drin lassen, weil wir machen halt kein Karaoke
in diesen Kreisen, sondern das mehr so mitsingen.
Ich traue mich mal eine Spekulation zu machen.
Das wäre super geil, wenn das alles,
das sind doch in der Frontend, GitHub hostet,
hier JavaScript. Genau, ich möchte
mal spekulieren, es gibt ja bereits
mehrere Apps, die einfach bloß darauf
basieren, dass da ein anderes Frontend zu YouTube sind,
zum Beispiel Playlist oder sowas,
oder einfach
spielen kannst. Ich gehe fest davon aus, dass
wir in spätestens fünf Jahren irgendwo eine App haben,
wo du Karaoke mit Freunden machen kannst, wo du
einfach YouTube-Links reinschmeißt und dann ist es ein Karaoke.
Mit Text und
mit der Punkt hopst von Wort zu Wort.
Ich hatte sowas schon mal angefangen. Tatsächlich
war das so ein altes Webprojekt von mir vor fünf Jahren.
Das war aber auf dem
Ultrastar-File-Format basierend.
Da hast du, also die Idee war,
ich bin nicht wirklich weit gekommen damit, die Idee war, dass du wirklich
so einen Ultrastar-Ordner auf die Webseite
drauf trackst im Web, weil da halt Rendering
für sowas einfacher war zu der Zeit, wahrscheinlich
sogar immer noch plattformübergreifend, es ist einfach nichts gibt.
Und du hast da dann die,
du hast ja in Ultrastar
hast du dann möglicherweise ein Video oder eine Grafik halt,
die das Hintergrundbild, du hast die Datei, wo die
Pitches drinstehen, die
Lyrics dazu und die Audio-Datei, die mit dazu
abgespielt wird und da musst du noch über
Mikrofone irgendwie ranbinden
und dann kannst du das halt da trackbasiert
damit singen. Das Projekt
habe ich liebevoll Frank genannt gehabt.
Schönen Gruß an unseren
Freund Frank, der ja mal die UltraStar-Karaokas
organisiert.
Die Idee damit, dass du das
vollautomatisiert jetzt hier ohne
Soße-Dateien zu machen, wäre natürlich
mega-fancy. Also, schön, dass
du dieses Thema angesprochen hast, denn
mir fallen spontan zwei Picks ein, die ich noch mit in den
Top werfe und ich glaube, damit haben wir auch genug
für heute. Und zwar, das eine Projekt
ist von
Lislis.
Lislis, die
heißt, steht das überhaupt auf ihrem
GitHub? Die hat schon auf
Rust-Festen Vorträge zum Thema Spieleentwicklung
mit Rust gehalten. So 2D-Spiele
und macht dann auch immer einen
2D-Spieleentwicklungs-Workshop.
Ziemlich coole Person.
Und
ich hab mal kurz auf ihr GitHub geschaut
und da gibt es ein schönes Spiel, das heißt
das habe ich gerade in die Shownotes geschmissen
Ukulele Hero.
Und das basiert auf
ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie es funktioniert, aber du hast
zwei, drei Tracks drin und dann kannst du mit der
Ukulele dazu spielen. Wie cool!
Genau, und dann sagt sie, wie gut du das spielst.
fand ich ziemlich nice.
Kennst du noch Threads on Fire?
Das war früher so ein richtig geiles Open-Source-Spiel,
was es quasi auf jeder Plattform gab.
Das läuft auch, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr.
Wahrscheinlich auf diversen Linux-Distros
findest du es immer noch.
Das war so ein Guitar Hero-Klon,
was aber die Idee dahinter hat,
es schießt sich ein bisschen scheiße auf dem Laptop,
vor allem auf dem MacBook mit Touch Bar,
wenn du die F-Tasten brauchst.
Und dann nimmst du deine Tastatur so in die Hand
mit der Gitarre, hast deine linke Hand
auf den F-Tasten oben
und deinen Daumen der rechten Hand
auf der Enter-Taste
und dann spielst du da quasi Guitar Hero-mäßig
mit der Hand.
Hendrik macht das gerade vor hier.
Du brauchst bloß F1 bis F4.
Ich glaube, der Extra-Modus ging noch bis zu F5 weiter.
Und dann hast du da...
Ich habe bloß noch das Tutorial
von dem Spiel im Kopf, weil dir der
Erzähler, der hieß, glaube ich, Jürgen Gunther
Schwarzenhafenstraßen,
hat den dann so fertig gemacht.
Gunther Schwarzenhafenstraßen.
Du musst sofort an der große Diktator von Chaplin denken.
und der hatte ich ja immer so fertig gemacht, weil du nicht spielen kannst
und er der Beste ist, aber es hat
super Spaß gemacht, vor allem weil es halt auch so
UltraStarStyle in der Community gab, von
die halt eigene Songs portiert haben
du brauchst die Audiodatei, du brauchst einfach nur die Datei
wo die, was du
wann drücken musst drin war und das hast du daneben gelegt
und dann konntest du da beliebig drin spielen
ThreadsOnFire
ThreadsOnFire.sourceforge
Ja, und es war 100% auf Sourceforge gehaustet
Schön, okay, das muss ich mir nochmal in Ruhe
zu Gemüte führen
die andere Empfehlung, da ich ja gerade so ein bisschen
auf so einem Web-Audio-Trip bin
habe ich nochmal ein bisschen geschaut
was gibt es denn da für schöne Tools und es gibt eine
wunderschöne Unterseite natürlich von
Chrome Labs
es gibt ein Tool, das dir
ich war kurz davor das selber zu machen, ich bin froh, dass ich es jetzt nicht mehr
machen muss, dass dir
du brauchst ja in Web-Audio so Pipelines zusammen
du hast unterschiedliche Web-Audio-Knoten
die dann also sich ein Gain erhöhen
einen Pitch verändern, irgendwas rausfiltern
Stereo-Kanäle splitten
wieder zusammenführen und verschiedene
eigene Freak Events,
eigenen JavaScript-Code
ausführen, der
sich eigen
selbstgeschriebene Filter auf dem Sound
ausfüllt. Und da baust du so Pipelines zusammen
und es gibt ein Tool,
das ist eine Chrome-Extension,
die heißt
Web Audio Inspector und da hast du dann in deinen
Dev-Tools
im Browser dann so eine
Pipeline an sich. Du machst einfach irgendwie,
gehst auf eine Seite, die macht Web Audio und dann
nach, ah, es gibt diese Audio-Kontexte,
was ist denn da zusammengesteckt?
Und dann zeigt er dir diese, wie in so
einem grafischen Programmieren
So wie in
Quartz Composer? Oder war das
Quartz Composer? Habe ich das gerade richtig im Kopf?
Diese uralte, tolle Mac-Software,
wo du halt, nicht uralt,
wo du so node-basiert Dinge
zusammensteckst. Ja, sieht so ähnlich aus, genau.
Ein Highlight der alten Mac OS.
Dieses Ding im Web,
dieser Web-Audio-Inspektor von
Chrome sieht ziemlich genau
so aus.
Du siehst hier in dem Screenshot, siehst du oben
halt so ein bisschen diese Web-Anwendung, die
irgendwas mit Audio macht, wo du hier irgendwie so
urig aus den Nutri-Knopf fasst. Das ist die Webseite.
Und hier unten siehst du halt,
was macht die da. Siehst du hier einen
Oszillator-Knoten,
der einfach bloß eine Frequenz erzeugt, die du steuern
kannst. Die gehen dann in zwei unterschiedliche Gain-Notes
rein und in noch einen dritten.
Dann geht es in einen weiteren Oszillator und dann kannst du
ja komplettes Synthesizer in JavaScript bauen.
Ich habe leider persönlich absolut null Gefühl
für Audio-Krams,
Aber cool finde ich das dennoch.
Es gab einen Vortrag, den ich dir echt empfehle.
Ich hoffe, die haben es mit dem Video mittlerweile hingekriegt.
Es gab einen Vortrag auf dem Rust-Fest,
wo einer was mit Web-Audio und Web-Assembly in Rust gemacht hat,
wo ich unbedingt hingehen wollte.
Und der hat nichts mit Audioverarbeitung gemacht.
Du kannst ja irgendwie dein Mikrofon anzapfen
und da irgendwie Rauschen rausfiltern.
Nee, der hat das einfach komplett als Synthesizer verwendet.
Und dann hat er den Talk angefangen mit,
also wisst ihr denn, was Live-Programming ist?
alle so, ja,
ja, nee.
Und naja, ich mache sowas super gerne,
aber meistens, wenn man sich auch so treffen findet,
dann sind das meistens nicht wirklich
Live-Programming-Partys,
sondern Installation-Partys, weil die Software,
die man installieren muss, so fürchterlich kompliziert ist.
Und dann hat er einen Vortrag darüber gehalten,
was das eigentlich alles ist und wie es funktioniert.
Und mitten in dem Vortrag habe ich mir gedacht,
Alter, nee, das ist so traurig. Gerade dieser Vortrag
ist relativ so
emotionslos und langweilig
gehalten. Und er hatte sogar diese ganz
Latex PDF Präsentations-
Bioslides. War eigentlich
schlimm.
Und dann zum Schluss hat er aber gesagt, so jetzt gebe ich euch
mal eine Demo.
Hat quasi ein Ding gebaut, mit dem er
mit einer eigenen Programmiersprache Synthesizer
in Rust programmieren kann. Und da hat er dann einfach
die Webseite aufgemacht. Ich habe mir danach gesagt,
ich muss mir die unbedingt mal raussuchen.
Hat diese Seite aufgemacht
und du hast eigentlich nichts gesehen, außer ein Textfeld.
Und dann hat er angefangen
zu tippen und dann hat es auch wie,
war irgendwie eine Spur.
Da hatten wir DSL, um
einen Sequencer zu bauen.
Jede Zeile war eine Spur.
Und dann hat er angefangen,
was zu schreiben und dann hat er erst bloß
umf, umf, umf
gemacht. Und dann hat er irgendwie
ein Parameter auf der Zeile verändern und dann war es
umf, umf, umf, umf.
Dann hat er so ein Grundbeat. Dann hat er irgendwie noch
auf dieselbe Zeile oder eine Zeile daneben
wo man was anderes geschrieben hat.
Das ist schon umf, umf, umf.
Hat zwei Instrumente. Und zum Schluss hat er dann wirklich
Und dann hat er dann die Sequences gesteuert,
indem er mal Zeilen auskommentiert hat
und mal Zeilen wieder angebracht hat.
Und dann zum Schluss hat er das ausgefädelt,
indem er der Reihe nach alle Zeilen auskommentiert hat.
Und dann hat sich das wieder abge...
Das war richtig geil.
Es klang zwischendurch,
da hast du richtig mitgewippt.
Das war fett.
Der Vortrag war Mist.
Nee, der Vortrag war nicht Mist,
aber der Vortrag war einfach so ein bisschen trocken.
Aber zum Schluss, diese Live-Teamer war super geil.
Und dann, als es vorbei war,
hat dann der eine von den Organisern gesagt,
ja, das war super geil, vielen Dank dafür.
hat das jemand von euch gefilmt?
Der hat nämlich gerade leider ein Videoproblem.
Nein.
Ich glaube, eventuell gibt es dann,
wenn ich das jetzt finde,
schmeiße ich das
mal mit in die Shownotes,
weil die Demo war einfach super gut.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall super cool.
Da gehen wir schauen.
Barcelona.
Naja, ich muss es mal raussuchen.
Ja, das war zumindest
meine Pics.
Schon wieder Web-Audio.
Bevor wir Schluss machen,
ich habe noch einen Link hier angeklickt,
den du mit reingepackt hattest
ins Pad.
Rust Tropes.
Und da finde ich ganz unten gerade die
Toilet Closure.
Das ist sehr geil.
A closure that takes one parameter
immediately drops it.
Ah ja, genau.
Die Syntax dafür, von wegen Pipe underscore Pipe
und dann runde Klammern auf und zu.
Sieht halt auch aus wie eine Toilette.
Es gibt
eine Syntax-Eule in Rust.
Syntax-Eule?
Ja, der Aul-Operator
oder so ähnlich sieht das aus.
Das muss ich mal raussuchen.
Hast du ihn schon gesehen?
Ja.
Zwischen Spitzenklammern
mal runde Klammern wie Augen und dann kommen wir dazwischen.
Genau. Sieht wirklich süß aus wie
eine Eule. Ist total nützlich.
So ein Asci-Emoji oder Hex-Emoji
oder wie die haben. Nächstes Mal können wir dann mal wieder mehr über
Dino reden. Da soll nämlich demnächst
ein 1.0 rauskommen. Du meinst den
XPP-Client oder was?
Ne, den Node.js
Nachfolger. Dino?
Deno. D-N-O?
D-E-N-O.
Geh mal auf D-E-N-O.Land.
Der Name
und der Domain gefällt mir sehr.
Secure Runtime
Das Logo ist schon super schick.
Secure Runtime von JavaScript und TypeScript.
Und eine neue Runtime
in Rust geschrieben.
Das machen wir mal nächste Woche.
Das wollen wir nächste Woche sagen.
Das machen wir mal nächste Folge.
Okay, ich glaube an dieser Stelle
können wir uns abrunden. Ihr habt sehr lange
durchgehalten mit uns. Vielen Dank.
Das war akronomisierbar
Folge 35.
035.
Mensch, wir werden langsam alt.
An dieser Stelle, wir wünschen euch noch eine wunderschöne Woche und viel Spaß mit den restlichen Podcasts in eurem Podcatcher.
Der nächste davon folgt bereits in 3, 2, 1...